le jour de grève est arrivé jeudi 19
janvier il est 14h et 3 minutes bonjour
bienvenue sur le Figaro live dispositif
spécial pour suivre la manifestation
parisienne de cet après-midi vous avez
vu les premières images on écoutera les
leaders syndicaux les leaders politiques
tous les experts du Figaro seront sur
splato a commencé par Marie Cécile
Renaud bonjour Marie-Cécile bonjour
du service économie du Figaro on tentera
également d'avoir une réaction du
président de la République qui est en
Espagne aujourd'hui tiens c'est une
surprise d'ailleurs qu'il soit en
Espagne enfin peut-être pas tant que ça
nous allons voir et pourquoi essayer
d'en discuter puis surtout nous serons
sur le terrain avec Vincent roseron
notamment Vincent est-ce qu'il m'entend
vous êtes place de la de la République
d'où s'élance le cortège est-ce qu'il y
a du monde déjà à Vincent
mais en Vincent n'est pas encore là bon
alors c'est toujours un peu compliqué
c'est début de manifestation parce que
il y a beaucoup de monde et parfois des
problèmes de réseau bon ben je commence
par vous poser des questions alors Marie
Cécile depuis qu'on nous en parlait de
cette manifestation ça y est c'est un
une journée importante pour le pays ah
bah oui c'est une journée importante
c'est une journée noire
là les manifestation paraît être très
suivie on voit les images du cortège qui
doit s'ébranler à partir de 14h et qui
va aller de la place de la République à
la place de la Nation il y a également
des des manifestations en province je
crois qu'on attend 200 points de
rassemblement prévu en France
et les selon les autorités on attendait
550 000 à 750 000 manifestants dont 80
000 dans la capitale et bon bien sûr
c'est une journée noire je suis en tenue
un peu sportive excusez-moi je suis venu
à vélo
pour aller au travail
sur 10 qui ne qui fonctionne simplement
un TGV sur 3 le métro est très perturbé
donc
oui c'est une journée de blocage une
journée noire bon regardez ces images
qui nous parviennent de la place de la
République ça y est je crois qu'on a
retrouvé Vincent roseron Vincent est-ce
qu'il y a du monde déjà est-ce que vous
avez aperçu des figures politiques
mais c'est normal il y a du réseau peu
de réseau quand il y a beaucoup de monde
comme ça on va voir si on peut retrouver
nos envies spéciaux on a plusieurs
équipes sur le terrain vous inquiétez
pas on va aller on va les retrouver et
essayons de faire un peu de pédagogie
Marie-Cécile
pour être clair avec cette réforme
qu'est-ce qui va changer bon alors je
pense que tout le monde a bien compris
qu'il y avait deux points essentiels
dans cette réforme d'une part le report
de l'âge légal il va passer de 62 ans
aujourd'hui à 64 ans ça sera applicable
à partir de 2030 64 ans pour les gens
qui partiront en retraite à partir de
2030 et à cela s'ajoute une accélération
de la durée de cotisation donc il va
falloir travailler plus longtemps pour
toucher une retraite à taux plein il
faudra avoir 172 trimestres
43 ans de cotisations pour pouvoir
toucher sa retraite à taux plein sinon
si vous n'avez pas tous les trimestres
une décote s'applique d'accord l'âge
d'annulation de cette décote et lui ne
change pas il reste fixé à 67 ans bon
mais voilà par exemple quelqu'un qui est
né en 1969 68 69 devront ces personnes
devront attendre 64 ans pour prendre
leur
retraite et devront travailler 172
trimestres bon c'est compliqué est-ce
que vous pensez que les Français ont
bien compris tout ça moi j'en suis pas
persuadé j'ai parlé des deux mesures des
deux mesures phares après il y a plein
de mesures d'accompagnement pour adoucir
un peu
cet effet pour les personnes qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt pour les
personnes qui ont des travaux il y a un
travail pénible donc il y a quand même
plein de mesures d'accompagnement
pour les fonctionnaires en catégorie
active pour les personnes en régime
spéciaux ces gens-là continu à partir
plutôt que les autres la mesure d'âge
s'applique à eux de font travailler plus
longtemps mais il continueront à
travailler plutôt que les autres donc
voilà
est-ce que nous avons Vincent roserons
Vincent mon cher oui ça y est vous êtes
là bon dites-moi est-ce qu'il y a du
monde ensemble est-ce qu'il y a des
leaders syndicaux des leaders politiques
autour de vous
oui alors effectivement je me trouve pas
forcément place derrière moi ça a l'air
un peu clairsemé mais c'est parce que je
suis pas du tout pour l'instant à
l'endroit de la de la manifestation en
tout cas pas très proche c'est-à-dire
République je suis à trois arènes métro
delà au niveau du métro Saint-Sébastien
Froissart et vous le voyez je vais vous
tourner un peu les images là vous allez
voir c'est le PCF qui est là avec Yann
brossa Fabien Roussel devrait arriver
d'ici quelques instants un peu plus de
ce côté de la rue de mon côté il y a LFI
qui est là où Mathilde de panneau
devrait tenir un point presse à partir
de 14h30 sinon marine Tondelier de
Écologie Les Verts c'est déjà exprimé
tout à l'heure à 13h15 et on a eu aussi
tous les leaders syndicaux les
principaux leaders syndicaux qui ont qui
ont parlé Martinez Laurent Berger qui
était là de la CFDT Philippe Martinez de
la société ce sont nos aussi déjà
exprimés Vincent vous essayez de les
avoir c'est le leader syndicaux s'ils
peuvent venir à votre micro on les
écoutera bien sûr est-ce que
ma récessile il peut y avoir un statu
quo est-ce que on se dire tiens pas
besoin de réforme moi je suis pas un
spécialiste je connais pas forcément les
tenants les aboutissants j'écoute des
économistes j'écoute des hommes
politiques j'écoute des journalistes je
sais pas où donner de la tête je sais
plus qui croient
je pense que tout le monde reconnaît
qu'il y a un problème un problème
d'équilibre du régime de retraite même
la CFDT a reconnu qu'il y avait ne nie
pas qui a un problème de déficit après
ils sont pas d'accord sur les réponses à
emporter eux disent qu'on pourrait par
exemple faire rentrer plus tôt les
jeunes sur le marché du travail ou qui
est une meilleure équité de salaire
homme-femme ça permettrait d'avoir plus
de cotisations ils sont pas d'accord sur
les les réponses à apporter mais sur le
constat tout le monde quand même
s'accorde à dire qu'il y a un déficit
que le régime des retraites sera en
déficit sur les 25 prochaines années et
donc le statu quo il est pas tenable il
y a une nécessité financière
d'équilibrer le régime et encore avec
cette mesure le gouvernement prévoit de
revenir à l'équilibre en 2030 mais c'est
avec un taux de chômage de quatre et
demi pour cent donc c'est quand même
très ambitieux
90%
voilà et
c'est en plus sans tenir compte des 30
milliards d'euros de déficit du régime
de la fonction publique que l'État
comble avec nos impôts donc voyez il y a
quand même une nécessité financière il y
a aussi une nécessité économique
pourquoi je vous rappelle que la France
est un pays qui a 3000 milliards d'euros
de dette que la note de la France a été
dégradée enfin dégradé mais mis sous
perspective négative en novembre dernier
on en a pas énormément parlé mais et
donc c'est la capacité de la France à
emprunter à avoir des taux d'intérêt qui
ne s'envolent pas avoir sa note
respectée et c'est aussi une question de
crédibilité de la France vis-à-vis des
partenaires européens ça fait des années
qu'on leur vend on va réformer que on va
se mettre dans les plans j'ai vu ça un
peu partout de certains hommes
politiques Florian Philippot par exemple
qui dit cette réforme c'est l'Union
européenne qui la veut qui nous la
réclame on est à la botte de l'Europe on
est obligé de la faire ben non mais on a
une crédibilité vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires européens on est tous
ensemble on sait le président s'est
engagé à revenir
sous le les 3 % de déficit du 3% du PIB
en 2027 si on veut tenir ses objectifs
et bien il faut absolument faire cette
réforme des retraites c'est le seul
moyen le seul levier pour retrouver une
marge de manœuvre financière donc c'est
aussi le respect de la parole de la
France vis-à-vis de ses partenaires
européens c'est
notre capacité à emprunter et à enfin
voilà à assurer notre dette donc c'est
très important et puis c'est une
nécessité financière une nécessité
économique c'est aussi une nécessité
politique pour Emmanuel Macron
la nécessité financière économique à
terme les Français peuvent le comprendre
je pense la nécessité politique les
Français et le besoin politique au
politique d'Emmanuel Macron persuadé que
ça les intéresse beaucoup vous voyez
d'accord ça bon pour Emmanuel Macron
c'est sa stature de réformateur c'est
c'était ça le projet depuis 2017 c'était
le réformateur mais est-ce que les
Français ont intérêt aussi à ce que ce
quinquennat soit un quinquennat pour
rien parce que si papa jusqu'au bout de
cette réforme pour ne plus rien faire
après donc ça veut dire qu'on perd
encore 5 ans donc c'est quand même aussi
l'intérêt des Français c'est l'intérêt
politique d'Emmanuel Macron mais c'est
aussi l'intérêt des Français que le pays
ne soit pas bloqué et ben voilà qui
puisse évoluer et
et avancer et avancer tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent sur Le Figaro.fr volpas
évidemment Requiem for a Dream vous êtes
nombreux également sur Youtube vous
n'hésitez pas à vous réagissez je lis
vos questions vos réactions je les
transmets à mes invités accessible
renouer la première d'entre eux
aujourd'hui on va retourner sur le
terrain dans un instant on me dira si
Vincent roseron peut répondre à nos
questions lui aussi il est dans la
manifestation et on va essayer de voir
tout ça alors rappelez-moi parce que ça
aussi c'est compliqué
on est sur une réforme paramétrique vous
me confirmez c'est-à-dire qu'on fait
bouger un paramètre
et la durée de cotisation et les autres
paramètres c'est quoi le montant des
pensions et le taux de cotisation ça on
y touche pas non est-ce qu'on appelle le
triangle infernal des retraites pour
ceux qui n'y connaissent rien comme moi
c'est difficile parfois à comprendre non
mais finalement c'est assez simple soit
vous baissez les pensions des retraités
socialement
c'est très compliqué de de baisser les
pensions de nos parents je ne suis pas
certaine la retraite moyenne elle est à
1400 euros c'est pas si élevé que ça
les retraités ils ont l'inconnu du vieil
du de la fin de vie est-ce qu'ils vont
devoir faire face à des dépenses de
dépendance il y a un EHPAD payer des
personnes à domicile vous voyez c'est
compliqué et donc de toute façon le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités il va
baisser c'est inscrits puisque les
retraites n'ont pas suivi l'inflation il
y a une désinsectection pendant des
années donc mécaniquement le pouvoir
d'achat des retraités déjà il va baisser
pareil
dans le sens de ce que vous m'avez dit
il y a quelques instants politiquement
les retraités sont très importants pour
Emmanuel Macron ils ont très largement
voté pour lui aux deux tours de la
présidentielle c'est vrai donc ça me
paraît difficile d'agir sur le montant
des pensions après vous disiez augmenter
les cotisations alors très bien mais je
vous signale quand même que la France et
le pays d'Europe qui a le plus le taux
de cotisation le plus élevé
et les cotisations elles sont payées à
60 % par les patrons mais 40% par les
salariés donc si vous augmentez les
cotisations bah c'est une perte de
pouvoir d'achat pour les actifs et puis
c'est aussi pénaliser les entreprises ça
alourdit le coût du travail ça nuit à la
compétitivité des entreprises françaises
par rapport à leurs concurrents
européens et une finesse ça se
retournera contre l'emploi parce que si
le haut du travail est trop élevé et ben
n'embaucheront pas on va parler dans un
instant de du taux de cotisation encore
parce que ça m'intéresse totalement
certaines personnalités politiques
notamment François Hollande en personne
la dit que ça pouvait intéresser
certains Français mais d'abord on
retourne sur le terrain Vincent roseron
vous êtes avec ça y est un leader
politique Yann brossa du Parti
communiste
oui
exactement je suis avec Yann Brossard du
Parti communiste de Monsieur brossage
j'imagine que pour vous et pas tout
particulier c'était très nombreux
c'était très important de se montrer
très nombreux aujourd'hui pour cette
journée de mobilisation ah ça c'est déjà
un objectif qui a atteint il y a
énormément de monde dans toutes les
manifestations en région on atteint des
scores de mobilisation exceptionnelle et
par ailleurs la grève aussi est très
massive j'étais tout à l'heure avec les
cheminots de la gare de Lyon c'est des
chiffres qu'on a pas atteint depuis des
dizaines d'années en termes de
proportions de grévistes donc je pense
que la démonstration de force c'est
d'ores et déjà réussi combien vous
pensez est-ce que vous pensez que il y a
un million de personnes dans les rues
aujourd'hui je n'en ai aucun doute enfin
les chiffres définitifs seront donnés
quand les manifestations se seront
tenues mais en tout cas c'est énorme et
je pense que le gouvernement n'aura
pourra pas tenir très longtemps comme ça
d'autant que le mouvement va assurer
dans la durée c'est ça alors aujourd'hui
il y a une manifestation mais l'idée
c'est voilà c'est d'arriver à continuer
et et que ce mouvement perdure dans la
durée comme vous le dites oui il y a une
double bataille il y a la bataille de
l'opinion publique et cette bataille là
elle est gagnée puisque l'écrasante
majorité des français et notamment de
ceux qui travaillent ne veulent pas de
cette réforme et puis deuxièmement il y
a la bataille de la mobilisation par les
grèves et par les manifs et cette
batailles là en tout cas la première
manche et gagner mais il est bien
évident que ce rapport de force il va
falloir l'inscrire dans le temps pour
que le gouvernement soit obligé de
reculer très bien merci beaucoup
du Parti communiste qui lui espère que
le gouvernement recule évidemment on
aura surtout des réactions dans la rue
de personnes qui sont favorables à cette
à cette qui sont favorables un retrait
de la réforme des retraites évidemment
oui je vous parlais de François Hollande
de gauche qui nous disait depuis
quelques jours qui nous dit depuis
quelques jours lui et ses amis
que finalement augmenter le taux de
cotisation c'était peut-être une bonne
idée que quelques Français préférait
peut-être payer un peu plus et voir leur
retraite rester à 62 ans et pas plus et
pourquoi ne l'est-tu pas fait je vous
pose la question est-ce qu'il ne l'a pas
fait lui pendant son quinquennat il a
fait la réforme Touraine du nom de
Marisol Touraine qui était la ministre
de voilà en charge des retraites et de
la santé
la réforme Touraine c'est une
accélération de la durée de cotisation
c'est le nombre de trimestres qui
augmentent là le gouvernement a repris
cette réforme mais en allant plus vite
avec la réforme Touraine on a augmenté
d'un trimestre tous les trois ans
c'était très long c'était assez malin de
la part de François Hollande parce qu'il
faisait une réforme des retraites mais
dont les effets ne se feraient pas
sentir sous son quinquennat donc moi
j'estime que c'est pas vraiment très
courageux politiquement donc revenir
maintenant en donnant des leçons aux
autres
voilà
donc la durée de cotisation je vous
disais elle est quand même déjà très
élevée et on est le pays d'Europe où
elle est la plus élevée donc c'est à la
fois privé les actifs de pouvoir d'achat
si vous faites ça et c'est aussi
pénaliser nos entreprises à réduire leur
compétitivité parce que nos entreprises
françaises elles sont dans le jeu
international sont pas toutes seules
donc il faut qu'elle puisse il faut pas
qu'elle court avec un boulet au pied
elles en ont déjà suffisamment
donc je ne pense pas que ce soit la
solution après personne n'a envie de
travailler et quoi que on a envie de
travailler plus longtemps mais c'est
finalement la moins douloureuse des
solutions voilà on a vu il y a quelques
instants sur les images
un homme défilé dans ce cortège un
certain Laurent Berger le boss de la
CFDT alors ça c'est presque la surprise
on sait depuis un moment mais c'est une
surprise puisqu'il y a deux ans trois
ans même maintenant il n'était pas
contre la réforme des retraites
d'Emmanuel Macron qui était différente
ceci dit mais il soutenait plutôt
Emmanuel Macron là ce n'est pas le cas
vous avez raison Thibault la CFDT était
tout à fait en soutien de la réforme de
2019 la réforme pour un système
universel et une retraite en point qui
ne prévoyait pas de report de l'âge mais
qui avait une vision c'est une réforme
systémique c'est-à-dire qu'on refaisait
on refondait le système de retraite
l'idée était de mettre plus de justice
plus d'équité etc et c'était une autre
vision de la société ont touché aux
pensions de réversion touchées au
trimestres pour enfants des femmes voilà
il y avait une refonte globale du
système
et la CFDT a toujours été favorable à ça
elle la CFDT elle se bat pour une vision
de la société et elle trouvait son
compte dans cette dans cette réforme
mais
là le problème de l'équilibre économique
de le problème du déficit du régime des
retraites c'est réinviter dans le débat
et nous sommes maintenant sur une
réforme paramétrique dont l'objet c'est
de rétablir les comptes c'est pas de
refonder un système puis bon les
Français on l'a vu avait beaucoup de mal
la première réforme était très
ambitieuse elle touche à plein de
paramètres en même temps finalement a
été trop trop complexe les retraites
c'est un sujet hyper sensible pour les
Français parce que ça touche à toute la
vie à la fin de vie qui a un moment
compliqué et donc
c'était trop complexe ça touchait à trop
de paramètres en même temps il faut y
aller quand même pas à pas et le
gouvernement a fait marche arrière
d'ailleurs même les députés avaient du
mal à défendre cette réforme sur
certains points tellement elle était
compliquée et large j'ai une question
sur Youtube elle est simple paradoxe qui
me la pose peut-on
rétropédaler sur cette réforme est-ce
que il y a une chance avec Cécile Renaud
qui Emmanuel Macron
se disent bon bah il y a trop de monde
dans la rue bon c'est trop compliqué à
la santé nationale je repousse cette
réforme non il n'y aura pas de
référendum je ne sais pas je n'ai pas de
boule de cristal la météo
c'est un élément très complexe personne
n'est capable de prévoir mais je pense
que Emmanuel Macron ne va pas faire
marche arrière je vous rappelle qu'en
2019 en décembre 2019 il y avait eu des
grèves massives très importantes c'était
des grèves les grèves les plus
importantes depuis les fameuses greffes
de 95 bah pour autant est-ce qu'il a
reculé
le covid est passé par là et la réforme
des retraites a été reportée
ce projet de loi il a été voté en 49-3
en première lecture à l'Assemblée il
fait partie au Sénat et Bing le covid
est arrivé donc tout s'est arrêté mais
le je me suis fait que le projet de loi
avait été voté on prévient lecture à
l'Assemblée et qui suivait son chemin
par le long terme il allait arriver au
Sénat et puis il sera revenu à la
semaine l'assemblée aurait eu le dernier
mot
voilà donc je ne vois pas pourquoi
cette fois-ci Emmanuel Macron reculerait
pourquoi n'a-t-il pas proposer à nouveau
cette réforme de 2019 si c'était si
simple à l'époque si vous me dites qu'il
était en train d'aller au bout pourquoi
il a intégré le fait que effectivement
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure la
réforme était trop complexe trop
difficile à appréhender et puis
lui est revenu en boomerang ce ce la
réalité économique nécessitait fait loi
aujourd'hui il y a un problème de
déficit alors que quand il est arrivé en
2017 le corps avait donné des prévisions
qui ont qui lui permettait de dire qu'il
y avait pas de d'urgence financière mais
la situation
les chiffres sont apparus et voilà donc
là il est contraint à mon avis il ne
fera pas marche arrière en revanche ce
que les manifestants peuvent obtenir les
opposants à la récente peuvent obtenir
ce sont des adoucissements à l'Assemblée
lors du débat parlementaire les
parlementaires peuvent apporter des
amendements il va y avoir une bataille
d'amende pour
essayer d'arrondir les ongles de de
voilà d'apporter des modifications
du sucré comme on dit dans le salé à
partir du sucré dans le salé alors
moi je mets aussi en garde parce que
cette réforme elle est quand même les
parlementaires
elle conseille à leur donner mais
faisons attention
que cette c'est toujours le problème
avec les réformes elles doivent générer
des économies c'est pour ça qu'on les
fait mais attention à ce que toutes les
mesures d'accompagnement ne viennent pas
grever et les économies attendues et les
que les mesures faites pour épargner
quelques-uns aussi justifier que ça
puisse l'être ne vienne pas grever les
économies les efforts de tous les autres
déjà Bruno Le Maire a expliqué que cette
réforme doit apporter en 2030 17,7
milliards d'euros d'économie le déficit
est auquel il faut déjà enlever 4,8
milliards d'euros de mesure
d'accompagnement on économise 17
milliards et on doit déjà dépenser 4
milliards 8 et c'est avant le passage à
l'Assemblée et c'est avant même
d'intégrer ces fameuses
rebalorisation des petites pensions
je vous dis que attention de ne pas trop
charger la barre des mesures
d'accompagnement parce que au final
je vous rappelle qu'Emmanuel Macron
pendant la a été élu et pendant la
campagne il prévoyait d'aller à 65 ans
vous avez raison vous avez raison il est
14h25 nous sommes en direct vous voyez
les manifestants qui affluent place de
la République avec ces images en hauteur
il avait du monde quand même nous
verrons les chiffres officiels en fin de
journée sachez quand même qu'on a des
premières remontées
des chiffres en région parce que les
manifestations dans les autres grandes
villes a eu lieu ce matin 30 000
personnes ainsi défilé à Toulouse 26000
à Marseille 15000 à Montpellier 14000 à
Tours 13600 à Pau etc etc mais sachez
que ce sont des niveaux comparables
voire supérieurs à ceux du 5 décembre
2010 9 au démarrage de la contestation
contre le stationnement projet de
réforme des retraites la police avait
compté alors licence 6000 manifestants
en France à ces résultats à l'époque
disait un million cinq est-ce que
Marie-Cécile honnêtement ces images vous
impressionnent est-ce que vous attendez
à ça ou non quand même là il y a du
monde
ça tombe tout le monde s'attendait à une
mobilisation importante une mobilisation
massive parce que les retraites c'est un
sujet qui touche tout le monde c'est
interprofessionnel ça touche toutes les
professions donc c'est ça mobilise
fortement et puis c'est tout à l'heure
c'est un sujet d'inquiétude forte parce
que quand on arrive à la retraite on
finalement on a pas les moyens de se
refaire si vous voulez
donc c'est un sujet très anxiogène
donc là le but pour les syndicats c'est
de dépasser le million de manifestants
est-ce qu'ils y seront bon on verra en
fin de journée eux disent déjà qu'ils y
sont vous j'ai noté quelques petites
déclarations qui ont été faites de
Laurent Berger qui s'est félicité d'être
au-delà de ce qu'on pensait Philippe
Martinez CGT dit le million de
manifestants va être dépassé
[Musique]
Yann brossade d'ailleurs il y a quelques
instants
a dit on a des chiffres de manifestants
en provinces qui sont considérables des
moyennes qu'on n'a jamais atteintes on
annoncé peut-être un million on y sera
et bien au-delà aujourd'hui
voilà donc ils sont tous très bon c'est
normal attendons la fin de journée pour
avoir les chiffres officiels mais
effectivement les images que vous
montrez montrent une
mobilisation importante mais ça c'était
attendu après la question et de savoir
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ensuite
est-ce qu'il est est-ce que on aura ça
tous les jours ou presque en tout cas à
chaque journée de mobilisation est-ce
que ça va s'essouffler alors c'est toute
la question de savoir
la question c'est qu'est-ce qui va se
passer ensuite
est-ce que ça va tenir quelle stratégie
vont adopter les syndicats donc ils
doivent parler ce soir ou demain c'était
pas complètement arrêté là mais
on va les entendre la journée
certains syndicalistes qui me qui
m'expliquait qu'en 2015 au moment de la
loi travail je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez de la loi el khomri la loi
travail ils avaient pas loin derrière
cette réforme
fait une quinzaine de jours de
mobilisation très importante
étalée sur trois semaines et au final
ils n'ont pas eu gain de cause donc
la question était de savoir est-ce qu'on
change de stratégie est-ce qu'on fait
des grosses journées de mobilisation sur
comme ça espacées ou est-ce qu'on fait
des des mouvements reconductibles sur
plusieurs jours donc je pense que ils
vont s'exprimer et on aura la suite des
événements
voilà avoir les réactions également
du gouvernement
le président de la République est en
Espagne avec 11 ministres est-ce que ça
vous a surpris que le président ne soit
pas en France aujourd'hui le présent et
puis les 11 principaux ministres il y a
pas de Bruno Le Maire il y a pas de
Gérald Darmanin par exemple
je pense que c'est un peu étonnant en
tout cas on termine l'image de
communication
comme si le président se désintéressait
mais on prend connais les agendas
présidentiels qui sont prévus longtemps
à l'avance et c'est parfois difficile
qu'est-ce qui est le plus marquant
Marie-Cécile la rue les images là de
milliers de personnes voire d'un million
de personnes qui défilent ou un blocage
du pays je pense au transport aux écoles
auraffinerie qu'est-ce qui peut qui
pourrait amener Emmanuel Macron à
desserrer la vis et pourquoi pas
renoncer alors finalement les transports
qui ont souvent focalisé l'attention
on va voir depuis le covid il y a quand
même deux éléments nouveaux c'est d'une
part le télétravail qui est entrée dans
les mœurs donc il y a alors bien sûr
tout le monde ne peut pas ne peut pas
faire de télétravail les infirmières à
l'hôpital elles peuvent pas faire
télétravail les sur les chantiers dans
le BTP les gens ne peuvent pas faire du
télétravail mais il y a quand même toute
une partie de la population qui
maintenant est outillée habitué les
entreprises ont fait leur
révolution culturelle bref le
télétravail est quand même entré dans
les mœurs donc on va voir dans quelle
mesure ça permet de
de contourner les blocages des
transports et il y a aussi l'émergence
du vélo des pistes cycla qui se sont
développées un peu partout
quasiment en piste cyclables de bout en
bout bref il y a quand même eu aussi des
travaux et les gens se sont équipés de
vélo et alors c'est peut-être très
peut-être plus parisien enfin plus
urbain effectivement dans les campagnes
les gens ont moins c'est peut-être ces
outils mais ils sont aussi moins
handicapés par les problèmes de
transport
pour l'instant parce que Clémentine
Autain l'une des leaders de la France
insoumise est en train de prendre la
parole on l'écoute
on doit entendre le message
est-ce que la connexion est bonne
particulièrement impressionnant aussi
parce que c'est dur de perdre un jour de
salaire dans le contexte actuel et donc
le gouvernement doit entendre et c'est
ça lui qui a les moyens aujourd'hui de
faire en sorte que voilà la situation
s'apaise et que les gens autour de
travailler c'est
une première ça faisait 12 ans qu'on
avait pas eu d'union syndicale 12 années
et je constate que voilà il a fallu être
patient il y a eu un travail que je
salue mais vraiment je salue entre les
syndicats et qui permet aujourd'hui
cette réussite travaille aussi de front
politique avec la nupesse qui a aussi
décidé de mener la bataille en commun à
l'Assemblée nationale
océan et je pense que c'est ça
ils sont là dans la rue pour faire
reculer le gouvernement sur deux années
de retraite supplémentaire
et entendre Clémentine notamment on a
bien compris qu'elle se félicitait de ce
front syndical elle a dit combien 14 ans
qu'il n'y avait pas eu une telle union
syndicales représentatives n'avaient pas
défilé de façon unanime et
toutes ensemble merci beaucoup
Marie-Cécile Renaud merci d'avoir
partagé un moment avec nous avant que
cette manifestation ne débute vous allez
être relayé tout au long de l'après-midi
par les différents collègues du Figaro
on retrouve Vincent roseron sur place
alors on a entendu des des leaders
politiques pour l'instant vous êtes avec
une manifestante mon cher Vincent
[Musique]
oui je suis avec une manifestante une
aide-soignante Patricia qui est avec
nous et je voulais lui demander alors
qui a ce panneau avec elle je lui
demandais pourquoi est-ce qu'elle était
là aujourd'hui pour manifester
aujourd'hui je manifeste parce que on me
dit que je pourrais partir cette année
avec 1600 euros alors que chez mon temps
de travail comme chez une carrière
longue et que si je pars pas je prends
deux ans supplémentaires et si je veux
partir entre ces deux ans je pars en
décote et je pars encore avec moi que ce
qu'on propose cette année pour vous la
situation est un peu
je ne sais pas quelle décision prendre
en sachant que si même si je la prends
là si je travaille en plus ce qu'on
m'autorise à faire comme j'aurais pris
ma retraite et ben je ne cotiserai plus
du tout pour ma retraite même dans le
privé parce que les lois sont passées
avant j'ai travaillé dans le privé et
tout en étant fonctionnaire ça ça
contraint mais pour 64 au lieu de 62 et
là malheureusement eh ben on me dit ben
tu peux travailler c'est imposable mais
tu travailleras plus pour ta retraite et
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
mobilisation aujourd'hui du nombre de
verdictions présentes elle est très
forte parce que nous sommes tous
nombreux il y a beaucoup de syndicats
qui sont représentés dans toute la
fonction moi je suis de la santé mais
j'ai des amis qui sont policiers qui
sont là des amis pompiers qui sont là
parce que nous travaillons avec eux et
on espère que il y aura beaucoup plus de
monde j'ai appris qu'il y avait des
champs d'accès aussi qui était là la
RATP la SNCF d'EDF et on espère que ça
va porter ses frais que Monsieur Macron
va revoir sa copie quoi merci beaucoup
voilà Thibault pour cette interview
d'une manifestante voici les images là
je trouve à côté du cortège de solidaire
ça pas encore débuté 14h34 je croyais
que ça devait partir à 14h faites pas le
parcours d'ailleurs on en a pas parlé je
crois
alors le parcours la manifestation on va
partir de la place de la République
place de la République qui est tout
là-bas au fond je sais pas si vous voyez
la statue qui est tout là-bas au fond et
qui va prendre donc la première rue qui
est pris c'est celle-ci le boulevard du
Temple qui devient vouloir de physique
Albert qui est tout là-bas et ensuite on
va aller jusqu'à la place de la Bastille
et une fois qu'on arrive à la Bastille
on va arriver à la place de la Nation
qui est là en fait le chemin habituel en
fait pour les grandes manifestations
parisiennes et la mutation vous m'avez
demandé si elle avait avancé déjà un peu
oui un petit peu elle a avancé un petit
peu pas beaucoup là il est on a
l'impression qu'elle est bloquée mais on
s'attendait à ça pas une imagination qui
démarre à 14h pile c'est sûr et avant de
faire une interview avec la manifestante
j'ai croisé pas mal de responsables
politiques Olivier Faure Mariton delier
qui essayait de trouver une place en
fait pour rentrer dans la manif mais je
les ai perdu donc je ne sais pas où
est-ce qu'ils sont partis
sans vous avez une mission vous avez une
mission les récupérer les retrouver nous
on continue bientôt Christophe cornova
bonjour bonjour Vincent moi c'est
Thibault oui oui je comprends bien avec
Vincent roseron qui est sur place
rédacteur en chef adjoint au service
société du Figaro spécialiste des
questions de sécurité et de
renseignements bon on aura des chiffres
officiels en fin de journée
quels étaient les attentes hier en fait
c'est toujours pareil c'est la prévision
c'est pas une science exacte évidemment
dans le en matière de maintien de
l'ordre et en fait ça évolué un peu à
mesure qu'on s'est approché de
l'événement c'est-à-dire que au tout
départ les policiers les salles de
renseignement le renseignement
territorial en particulier estimé entre
on va dire 500 à 650700
000 d'accord
et dans la soirée ils ont revu leur
chiffre et ils ont dit on pourrait
atteindre les 800 000 ah oui aujourd'hui
je viens de faire un point avec eux
enfin avec des des analystes de la Place
Beauvau et l'un d'entre eux m'a écrit
que je cite
l'hypothèse haute ça veut dire des des
800000 sera atteinte et voir dépasser
alors c'est lié donc on dépasserait les
800000 dépasserait
tout à l'heure les les chiffres en
région parce que les manifestations
notamment à Marseille à Nice à Lyon ont
lieu plutôt aux alentours de 10h 11h
midi donc on a déjà des chiffres et
apparemment ils sont plutôt élevés ils
sont élevés effectivement Thibault parce
que
par exemple les policiers ils avaient
dit à Marseille ils seront autour 25000
là on est à 26000 donc peu court on est
à peu près dans le même dans le même
configuration en revanche il y a des
surprises à Nantes par exemple ça a
énormément mobilisé c'est à dire que il
faut se rappeler que Nantes une ville
comme Nantes en 2010 pendant la la
première réforme lune enfin de
nombreuses vous avez raison celle qu'on
a qu'on a qu'ils ont recensés comme
comme modèle
2010 donc c'était celle où on passait de
de 60 à 60 ans il y avait 10 000
manifestants à ce moment d'accord en 19
en 2019 quand il décembre juste avant le
covid juste avant le covid quand il
s'est agit de de réfléchir à à cette
retraite à point là il y avait 20 plus
de 20000 personnes et là aujourd'hui
1000000 on est à plus de 30000 ah oui
donc c'est à dire que là on commence à
crever des plafonds et alors ce que me
disent et c'est encore plus intéressant
les les services
spécialisés c'est que notamment
ça pousse très très fort dans les
petites et les moyennes villes j'ai vu
ça aussi par exemple Pau 13600 12000 à
Perpignan
on n'a jamais vu ça par exemple une
ville comme gars dans les Alpes du Sud
dans le gardes
ou alors Ding j'ai noté il y a plus de
5000 personnes oui c'est énorme
à l'échelle de la taille à l'échelle de
la ville à Mont-de-Marsan plus de 5000
personnes il y a des villes où ça se
manifestaient jamais ou très peu genre
Verdun c'est pas non plus le non on se
dit pas le foyer de la France sociale en
français bah là il y avait plus d'un
millier de manifestants sur 20 000
habitants de la commune c'est à dire que
tout d'un coup il y a un
étalement de la de la de la colère en
tout cas de la contestation sur
l'ensemble du territoire et dans les
replis en profondeur du pays mais
on donne des chiffres qui sont élevés en
nombre de manifestants combien de
personnes étaient attendues hier soir à
Paris alors à Paris on avait une
fourchette entre 50 et 80 000 donc si on
suit votre logique il y aura plus de
100000 personnes à Paris la logique
haussière qu'on constate visiblement
dans toutes les villes de France il y a
plus de 100000 personnes cet après-midi
à bien dans les rues de Paris ce qu'on
pourrait dire Thibault c'est que au
moins on va rester sur l'hypothèse haute
80.000 ce qui me semble effectivement
quand on voit les images de la
mobilisation
de la place de la République
qui en plus vous avez vu débordes sur
les sur les artériales on est vraiment
en droit d'imaginer que le chiffre de 80
000 est et sera le très très largement
atteint après on va peut-être attendre
la fin de la journée pour pour compter
de manière définitive mais en tout cas
ce qui est clair c'est que la
mobilisation la cristallisation de la de
la fronde et peut-être plus forte que ce
qu'on pouvait attendre
dans les heures qui viennent avec les
chiffres qui vont commencer à remonter
il y a plusieurs manifestations partout
en France est-ce que c'est toujours
comme ça j'ai le souvenir qu'on disait
allez on monte tous à Paris ah c'est pas
le cas 200 250 points de manifestations
c'est entre 220 et 250
a priori
là on est dans un schéma de journée
nationale d'action c'est-à-dire que un
peu comme à l'époque de la contestation
de la loi
2015 tout à fait jusqu'à début 2016 il y
a eu cette effectivement des Journées
Nationales où il y avait finalement des
foyers un peu partout dans le pays ça
dépend véritablement de du mode
d'organisation là les syndicats décidés
que on le ferait de manière unitaire et
partout en France
gardons en mémoire que samedi la France
insoumise elle a décidé de faire
l'inverse c'est-à-dire que ce sera une
marche unitaire dans la capitale et donc
c'est à dire que là on sera sur
peut-être des chiffres encore plus forts
en tout cas dans Paris en définition que
ceux qu'on a actuellement nous verrons
parce qu'il y a pas forcément l'appel
les syndicats là c'est une journée ou
les syndicats et les partis politiques
semblent se retrouver c'est pas
forcément le cas sur la ça sera une
manifestation
expliquez-moi Christophe ça m'intéresse
parler de ces chiffres mais comment on
les connaît comment on les prévoit
comment travaille les services de
renseignement pour avoir déjà des
données et puis essayer d'imaginer la
tendance de la de la mobilisation
alors
beaucoup de précautions beaucoup de
pincettes je vais prendre toutes les
précautions
de capteurs qui qui sont travaillés par
les services alors maintenant il y a
notamment les les réseaux sociaux
c'est-à-dire que dès que quelqu'un lance
faire un appel à manifester il y a les
pages Facebook et aller compte twitter
etc d'accord là on peut déjà mesurer
mesurer
ça donne
une lecture après il y a aussi le
travail à l'ancienne je dirais
celle des renseignements généraux qui
étaient là dans les assemblées générales
quel est le contact des organisateurs
qui prenaient le pouls un petit peu de
de ce mouvement c'est-à-dire du travail
de d'accord département par département
antenne départementale par Antenne
départementale du renseignement tout ça
remonte à Paris fait une synthèse et et
vient corrober ou non les premières
lectures que l'on a pu avoir sur les
réseaux sociaux et enfin c'est un
recoupe tout ça et puis après il y a
aussi des indicateurs purement
on va dire
mécanique du genre si vous faites une
manifestation à Paris vous comptez le
nombre de bus ah oui voilà donc les
beaucoup par exemple le nombre de bus
qui monte sur Paris peuvent donner une
lecture un peu plus corrigée par exemple
si on a un préavis de grève à SNCF avec
un taux de grève important on peut déjà
imaginer qu'il aura du monde dans la rue
d'accord exactement et d'ailleurs et
vous avez même parfois vous ça peut ça
peut prendre des formes sur des flux de
covoiturage en fait etc etc donc ça veut
dire que en fait il y a pas une science
exacte c'est un comme dans toutes les
affaires de police et de renseignement
c'est le croisement d'un certain nombre
de données plus ou moins objectifs il
dessine une fourchette vous avez vu tout
à l'heure qu'on disait entre 600 et 800
000 entre 50 et 80 000 à Paris sachant
que après il y a des fêtes surprise là
par exemple dans les petites villes et
difficile
quand les services de renseignement
c'est la nature des manifestants est-ce
qu'ils peuvent savoir et est-ce qu'on
sait sur cette journée de de grève de ce
jeudi 19 janvier s'il y a des gilets
jaunes des membres des gilets jaunes des
manifestants issus des gilets jaunes
dans ces cortège alors bien évidemment
il y en aura mais je pense que leur
présence
restera relativement un salaire les
dernières les dernières les derniers
rassemblements des gilets jaunes auront
peu ou
fédérer à travers le pays jusqu'à 4000
personnes c'est-à-dire 4000 versus on va
dire 800000 etc donc pire que on était
très on est très loin des 200000
d'ailleurs des premières c'était en 2018
donc 4000 c'est vraiment un tout petit
échantillon les derniers résistants quoi
exactement là on est véritablement pas
sur une queue de comète mais sur un
dernier quarteron de gens qui sont
radicalisés et dont les spécialistes
savent déjà qu'ils n'auront a priori
aucune possibilité de reprendre la main
sur ce mouvement social qui est quand
même bien tenu avec cadenacé par les par
les syndicats parce que cette impulsion
bien tenue bien qu'il y a de Nasser
justement
pendant la période des gilets jaunes on
s'est dit des syndicats sont morts ils
arrivent plus à tenir
le peuple si je veux dire les gens qui
manifestent les gens qui ont envie
d'aller dans la rue
ils ne seront plus représenter là c'est
pas le cas sur une manifestation comme
ça il y a les services de
sécurité des syndicats tout le monde est
là c'est la CGT qui décide et la CFDT
les autres qui décide de cette
manifestation qui va te taulière de la
manif exactement c'est à dire que en
fait il faudrait il est clair que le
syndicalisme n'a peut-être pu la
puissance qu'il a eu il y a il y a 30 ou
40 ans mais il serait je pense que ce
sera une grosse erreur de de considérer
que ces forces syndicales sont en sont
en voie de disparition d'ailleurs s'ils
arrivent à fédérer un million de
personnes dans la rue ils auront rempli
leur Paris qui n'étaient pas forcément
évident il y a encore 15 jours et par
ailleurs
on peut remarquer que ces syndicats
arrivent à fédérer extrêmement large
c'est à dire que bah il fait d'air
évidemment
dans leur dans leur bassin habituels qui
sont la fonction publique l'énergie les
transports etc mais vous allez là dans
cette manifestation et c'est ce que
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on c'est ce
qu'attendait aussi les services de
police et dans le gendarmerie vous avez
aussi des de la contestation plus
spontanée qui se greffe à ce mouvement
syndical
vous allez me parler de tout ça des
retraités des jeunes on attend de savoir
si eux seront dans la rue mais d'abord
on va dans la rue justement avec Vincent
roseron Vincent vous êtes avec un
manifestant un manifestant casque est
visiblement oui
alors je suis avec un manifestant avec
Jean-François qui a avec lui c'est
énorme alors je sais pas si c'est les
corbeaux qui voilà
ce que vous avez fait pourquoi c'était
important pour vous d'être là
aujourd'hui
pourquoi je suis là aujourd'hui
je suis venu pour manifester mon
opposition à cette réforme des retraites
que je juge absolument injuste et
injustifié
on n'a pas besoin de ça et je suis pas
tout seul à le penser donc je suis venu
apporter par solidarité mon soutien à
cette opposition là et j'ai voulu faire
aussi avec attaque parce que c'est une
forme qui me plaît de le faire dans
quelque chose d'un peu festif et joyeux
avec des arguments
pensés mais aussi une forme drôle quoi
on en parlait de la mobilisation est-ce
que vous êtes satisfait de la
mobilisation qui aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que quand même beaucoup de
monde alors je m'attendais à quelque
chose de d'assez fort là j'ai eu
quelques chiffres sur des des
rassemblements dans d'autres villes de
France ou apparemment c'est assez gros
et assez énorme donc pour l'instant
c'est encore un peu tôt pour en parler
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est que
c'est assez fort la suite après il va
falloir continuer vous allez continuer à
vous mobiliser on imagine
je vais continuer à mobiliser ouais bien
sûr et puis je pense que
j'attends et j'espère des formes de
mobilisation forte qui peuvent aller
même au-delà de ces manifestations des
grèves des blocages enfin le maximum
parce que le gouvernement a pas l'air
tellement de d'être à l'écoute et de
d'être en situation de d'entendre le
dialogue donc
j'ai l'impression qu'il a besoin de
raccords de force encore plus fort donc
oui oui je vais continuer à venir pour
ma part en tout cas dans les
manifestations et attendre plus de forme
de grève et de blocage merci beaucoup
alors je vais vous montrer du coup les
les fameux corbeau qu'on voit depuis
tout à l'heure de attaque dont le cirque
[Musique]
corbeaux avec même certains avec le
visage du président de la République
au-dessus
ce monsieur nous attendait je viens avec
une
espérant qu'il y a une ambiance bonne
enfance a l'air d'être le cas pour
l'instant mais il y a un dispositif de
sécurité important qui est prévu
Christophe il y a un dispositif de de
sécurité qui est très important à très
important c'est à dire que on est donc à
l'échelle nationale 10.000 policiers qui
sont spécialisés dans le match les
gendarmes
CRS et les gendarmes mobiles c'est
surtout essentiellement les CRS les
gendarmes mobiles et avec appui
territoriaux d'unités comme à Paris par
exemple la direction de l'ordre public
la circulation
et puis si on va un peu plus loin dans
la dans la dans l'intervention c'est à
dire là c'est pour encadrer la manif et
si le la déborde de la casserole et
qu'il y a des manifestations un peu plus
violents il y a en deuxième rideau les
brigades anti-criminalité et donc ce
qu'on appelle les fameuses braves
notamment pour ceux qui se déplacent
c'est sa moto les brigades d'action
anti- euh de répression d'action
violente d'accord voilà
10000 c'est important là sur alors c'est
toujours pareil c'est en prévision de ce
qui pourrait se passer c'est en
prévision de ce qui pourrait se passer
du l'âge de personnes moi j'ai eu à la à
Paris on vient de recevoir un message
donc qui me dit que à l'heure où l'on
parle il y a eu enfin peu avant 14h il y
a eu on était déjà 2300 contrôles
préventif dans la capitale d'accord
et 15 une quinzaine d'interpellations
principalement pour des ports d'armes
prohibés mais on me disait à ce stade
bonne physionomie générale c'est à dire
d'accord on n'est pas sur quelque chose
de tendu en revanche il faut savoir que
ces manifestations là sont des
manifestations considérés à risque qu'on
regarde du nombre
potentiel de de manifestants
et du côté un peu inflammable
du sujet qu'il est il est qu'il est
réuni mais donc pour faire pour éviter
qu'il y a trop de débordements il y a eu
quand même des choses qui ont été faites
en amont c'est à dire que notamment il y
a eu une inspection des parcours qui a
été faite hier vers notamment à Paris
entre la République et la place de la
Nation les policiers ont remonté m par
mètre tout le parcours de part et
d'autre de la rue on essaie de retrouver
comme on l'a vu pendant le précédentes
manif des des caches d'armes par
destination donc les manifestants
commencent dans les jours avant la
manifestation a posé je sais pas dans un
pot de fleur dans une poubelle
exactement et donc
pour éviter de se faire prendre la main
dans le sac avec des avec une batte de
baseball ou avec avec des objets
incendiaires il est prédisposé sur le
long du parcours pour s'en emparer et au
moment il passe et le jeter
le nettoyage a été fait ça c'est une
première chose et puis après il y a eu
donc c'est 2300 contrôle préventif en
amont de la manif c'est-à-dire que tous
les gens qui avaient un profil un peu
peut-être
suspect lutter contre les et enfin il y
a quand même aussi tout ce qui est
défense passive de la ville ce qu'on
appelle la défense passive c'est-à-dire
que on a vu
les commerçants ce barricader protéger
leur vitrines on a vu que les banques
ont protégé les distributeurs
automatiques de billets par des des
coffres métalliques oui alors ça c'est
c'est presque les commerçants eux-mêmes
qui font le job et qui font le travail
et qui mettent une
des squats des grands morceaux des plus
grandes planches de bois surtout sur les
Champs-Élysées par exemple sur les
Champs-Élysées là on le verra sur les
grands axes qui mène de la République à
Bastille puis de Bastille à la nation
l'idée c'est que
ces commerçants il faut quand même
garder en mémoire qu'à l'époque des
gilets jaunes
nombre d'entre eux ont vu leur activité
dévastée et et au sortir de la pandémie
sortir d'une période où tout est devenu
très cher l'idée de l'idée de de d'être
pillé par par une nuée de criquets c'est
pas bon je vous annonce le président de
la République en Espagne vous savez
peut-être et que on va avoir des images
dans quelques instants parce que il
n'est pas tout seul il est avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin il y a 11 ministres avec
le président de la République en Espagne
pour ce sommet qui était prévu de longue
date ce sommet franco-espagnol est-ce
que ça surprend ça étonne les forces de
l'ordre de voir leur ministre absent
alors qu'on le sait il y a un risque de
débordement dans ce manifestation
a priori on peut imaginer effectivement
que le ministre de l'Intérieur est
vocation à rester sur le territoire
national pendant les périodes de fortes
tensions sociales
[Musique]
l'emmener demeure pas moins que
j'imagine j'en suis même
incertitude c'est que il doit être
informé minute par minute et tout ce qui
se passe d'accord
il a son directeur vous pouvez voir de
Barcelone alors on va demander à Ryan
Becky en résine nous montrer tout ça
parce qu'il y a plusieurs ministres qui
sont en train de signer petit à petit
des j'imagine des accords avec avec les
Espagnols on me dira quand on pourra
manger
parce qu'il y a des migrants
c'est quand même un certain partenaire
de premier plan on voit ces images
monsieur Sanchez monsieur Macron qui
sont ensemble et on voit d'ailleurs
Gérald Darmanin regardez à gauche de dos
il est là le ministre de l'Intérieur il
se lève justement
[Musique]
de la gendarmerie Christian Rodriguez
qui ont chacun une main assez forte sur
les sur les unités
après faut voir si
il va passer la journée et passer la
nuit à Madrid je sais pas ce qui va
rentrer rapidement 2 heures d'avion il
va peut-être revenir vous avez ces
images donc en direct depuis Barcelone
on va repasser également sur les images
à Paris parce que c'est ce qui nous
intéresse tout particulièrement et puis
on suivra évidemment la potentiel
déclaration du Président de la
République parce que je suis certain que
les journalistes sur place ne passeront
pas à côté de l'occasion de lui poser
une question sur ce qui se passe dans
les rues parisiennes allez je continue
avec vous Christophe sur cette black
bloc on a entendu à chaque manifestation
est-ce qu'il y en a comment on les
repère ces black-box alors les Black
Blocs déjà c'est sans remonter à des
périodes en tête et du Vienne c'est
quand même pas très jeune c'est c'est
des mouvements qu'on connaît assez bien
quoi parce que ils ont les ça remonte à
plus de 40 ans c'était dans les années
80 en Allemagne on appelait à l'époque
les schwarzen block start and block
d'accord
oui merci c'est à ma deuxième langue
donc je me suis bien battu et en fait
c'était
[Musique]
dans les squats et les squats un peu de
berlinois etc de toute la tout le côté
un peu punk on the ground etc et en fait
il commençait un peu à avoir des des
vérités de revendications etc et après
ce mouvement de Black Blocs est monté en
puissance il s'est transposer aux
États-Unis avec très brièvement pendant
la guerre du golf en 1990 à Washington
ils ont commencé à vraiment être très
beau Jaillant et puis après on les a vu
arriver en France avec surtout 2016 qui
a été sérieux finalement en France en
France
j'imagine qu'il y a toujours eu des
cases dans les dans les manifestations
de Black Bloc qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
différents et bah justement bah en fait
c'est lié alors alors leur look alors
leur tenue d'accord avec le Black Bloc
c'est pas alors le Black Bloc c'est pas
il faut déjà ce qu'il faut bien c'est
hyper important c'est que les gens
pensent souvent que le black bloc c'est
un groupe de gens qui semblent c'est à
dire je fais pour je fais partie du
mouvement Black Box pas du tout les
Black Blocs c'est une technique
dans cette technique vous pouvez avoir
des gens de l'ultra gauche des
anarchotonomes des libertaires des
étudiants qui s'ennuient
des des hadistes c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
c'est une technique c'est un mode
opératoire le mode opératoire s'explique
très simplement vous êtes en tenue
normale comme comme vous quibo peut-être
magnifique
et après tout d'un coup vous ce qu'on
appelle dans le technique dans le mot
policier vous vous décidez vous changez
de silhouette vous passez tout de suite
vous avez des vêtements vous mettez en
noir pendant très rapidement pour faire
cela vous masquez évidemment et vous
mettez des gants et ça ne peut se faire
que quand la manifestation a un certain
nombre de personnes faites pas dans mes
pièces de 1000 personnes je rappelle que
Christophe Cornavin n'est pas en train
de vous donner le manuel du gentil Black
Bloc ça
on apprend comment ça et en fait donc il
se silhouette il passe à l'action
donc harcèlement action comme des Red
coups de poing alors ils attaquent les
évidemment les symboles de l'État les
symboles du capitalisme évidemment tout
ça et de et d'inspiration d'ultra gauche
dans l'écrasante majorité et une fois
qu'ils ont une fois qu'ils ont qu'ils
ont frappé je dirais ils se ils se
redessinent et se remettent en dans la
foule il retourne dans la foule et ils
sont donc proprement enfin difficilement
alors ce que je comprends pas c'est que
j'ai vu votre article qui nous dit qu'il
pourrait y avoir 600 600 black bloc à
Paris apparaît entre 200 et 400 c'est
une estimation d'accord mais alors si on
arrive à savoir ça pourquoi on n'arrive
pas à les attraper avant parce que vous
me dites qu'ils sont sur les réseaux
sociaux si on arrive à les patrons sur
les réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
mais on peut pas les attraper c'est je
pense que les gens et du coup vous avez
à comprendre ça moi j'ai du mal à dire
qu'en fait c'est à dire qu'en fait la
difficulté des de pour travailler sur le
phénomène Black Box c'est qu'en fait
c'est
sont une culture du secret c'est à dire
c'est un activisme à l'ancienne
concrètement
un black bloc ça va être du bouche à
oreille d'ailleurs en gros
c'est une sorte de cooptation
voilà c'est ça et donc en fait donc pour
pénétrer cette sphère cet écosystème
c'est pas simple donc il faut en gros
avoir des ce qu'on appelle des sources
des indices des informateurs qui peuvent
vous donner des tendances mais une fois
que vous avez ça c'est pas
sur le terrain pour les interpeller
c'est hyper dur parce qu'en fait ils ont
une stratégie de ce qu'on appelle de
recomposition perpétuelle c'est à dire
que ils attaquent pas forcément tout son
groupe c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent par
petit groupe harceler les forces d'un
côté se replier disparaître secret dans
un autre donc c'est c'est assez éclaté
et donc il y a le défi l'étage dont je
vous ai parlé et la dernière chose qui
n'est pas la moindre c'est que le
politique
pendant très longtemps n'a pas voulu
[Musique]
rechigner un peu à aller au contact avec
les Black Blocs parce que dans les Black
Blocs il y a c'est quand même des gens
qui ont un niveau culturel qui sont
parfois assez élevés des gens de des
lycéens de lycée assez prestigieux voir
de
d'université plusieurs fois c'est un bon
niveau social c'est un très bon niveau
social c'est des gens parfois qui
peuvent se retrouver dans des ce qui ont
aussi des concours assez élitiste et
donc en gros dès qu'il y a des jeunes
le politique n'a pas forcément envie
d'aller dessus Christophe on va devoir
enchaîner mais j'ai encore deux petites
questions je vous demande de me répondre
rapidement est-ce qu'on surveille aussi
l'extrême droite alors très rapidement
l'extrême droite mais c'est pas
forcément le plus gros souci en fait
l'idée c'est que on vous il y a parfois
des groupes d'extrême droite qui veulent
s'instiner dans les manifs et ça peut
frotter créer des frictions mais assez
marginales d'accord
petite question est-ce que la CGT a
c'est garde du corps on a j'entends
souvent à l'époque le service de l'ordre
de la CGT c'était quelque chose
maintenant ils font n'importe quoi et
ils arrivent plus à tenir leur foule
est-ce que c'est le cas où est-ce que il
y a quand même des gens qui tiennent les
manifestants moi je me souviens quand je
suivais des manifestations il y a 20 ou
25 ans sur le terrain pour le pour le
CIP au niveau des manifestations plus
anciennes on avait un service d'ordre
notamment de la CGT qui était tout à
fait exceptionnel et qui n'avait rien à
niveau comparable à celui des forces de
l'ordre classique c'est-à-dire des gens
qui étaient extrêmement solides avec des
anciens dockers des anciens ouvriers du
livre aujourd'hui
on a des SEO qui sont encore assez
solides mais un peu moins puissant qu'il
ne l'était avant tout simplement parce
que il y a moins d'adhérents et puis et
puis il y a des professions qui ont
disparu
ou qui sont moins importantes que
qu'avant donc le service d'ordre et
peut-être moins étoffé mais ça reste des
gens relativement sérieux les dernières
questions très rapidement je suis désolé
Christophe mais on attend Sophie taré
qui va nous parler des profs et puis on
va aller voir Vincent roseron sur place
pour voir quel est l'ambiance j'ai
l'impression pour l'instant la
manifestation est à l'arrêt ils ont le
droit de grève les policiers j'entends
qu'ils sont plusieurs à aller dans la
rue finalement ça c'est un peu
d'échauffé cette histoire non alors en
fait non non les policiers ils ont
absolument pas le droit de grève
un métier de souveraineté comme comme
les gendarmes comme les militaires comme
les magistrats c'est à dire que
pouvais pas de se dire bah non
aujourd'hui je vais mettre en revanche
en fait les policiers ils ont en fait un
régime spécial
qui fait que en gros voilà c'est en fait
et ce qu'on appelle c'est un système
central dans le détail de bonifice
quinquennale c'est-à-dire que tous les 5
ans ils ont une année de cotisation en
plus de gagner pour la toucher il faut
qu'il fasse 27 ans dans la maison
voilà et donc c'est-à-dire qu'ils
peuvent partir assez tôt si
si on avait touché à ce régime spécial
là je vous promets qu'il y aura eu des
problèmes il y aura eu des
manifestations en revanche ils vont
reculer l'âge de départ comme tout le
monde prendre deux ans dans la dans la
figure si je veux dire ils vont reculer
un petit peu ils sont pas d'accord ils
disent on va pas commencer à courir
après les voyous à 55 ans
ça c'est sûr que c'est sûr que si vous
êtes par exemple dans une brigade
antique criminalité et que vous êtes
dans le dans des quartiers dans des
quartiers chauds vous n'aurez pas la
même vélocité dans l'interpellation
mais après c'est une administration qui
compte 147 000 personnes et et un
inventaire de boulot extrêmement riche
donc après je pense qu'on peut toujours
trouver sa carrière dans une autre
branchement ou je sais je ne sais où
voilà merci beaucoup Christophe Cornavin
merci d'être venu si jamais en fin de
journée il y a des incidents vous nous
ferez parvenir toutes les informations
on suivra tout ça sur Le Figaro.fr et on
espère évidemment que ça se passe bien
Vincent roseron Vincent vous êtes
toujours dans la manifestation vous êtes
avec un manifestant visiblement le
cortège est à l'arrêt non oui
alors attendez
assez mal ici parce qu'il y a quand même
Christophe Cornavin nous quitte Vincent
roseron visiblement à des soucis de
connexion on va récupérer les images
voilà de la place de la République et
Sophie de Tarlet venez rejoignez-moi
cher Sophie
rédactrice en chef du Figaro étudiant
bonjour Sophie on va changer votre nom
voilà non c'est pas encore
François-Xavier c'est Sophie Tarl et
François-Xavier qui arrivent tout à
l'heure pour nous parler de politique
grande journée dispositif spécial autour
de ces journées de cette journée de
mobilisation de manifestation et on va
parler des profs on va essayer de
retrouver Vincent roseron mais
évidemment il a l'air d'avoir du monde
et le réseau est un peu capricieux
Sophie les profs sont dans la rue pas
forcément très étonné
dans la rue et puis aussi les jeunes on
va parler de tout ça vous avez raison de
parler des jeunes puisque vous êtes je
rappelle la directrice en chef du Figaro
étudiant bon parlant des profs d'abord
mobilisation moins importante que ce
qu'on croyait non j'ai vu passer des
chiffres ce matin oui un peu moins en
primaire par exemple un peu moins de la
moitié s'est mis en grève et c'est vrai
que c'est un peu étonnant mais je pense
que ceux qui en a quand même pas mal qui
sont venus manifester aujourd'hui et il
y a plusieurs il y a pas que la réforme
des retraites qu'il est mobilise il y a
aussi évidemment toute la partie des
salaires qui qui avec le l'inflation
avec les revendications salariales avec
les réformes de Blanquer qui avait eu
lieu enfin il y a beaucoup de
revendications autour de beaucoup de
choses qui crient les enseignants donc
c'est pas uniquement la réforme des
retraites mais bien sûr c'est important
pour eux parce que c'est pour eux ben
ils pratiquent un métier un métier
fatiguant épuisant nerveusement et ils
ne veulent pas poursuivre leur carrière
évidemment jusqu'à 64 ans il faut pas
oublier qu'il y a beaucoup de femmes
parmi eux les enseignants sont d'abord
en majorité des enseignants d'accord et
beaucoup ont parfois des carrière un peu
hachées on dû ont dû s'arrêter pour des
grossesses et où on commençait un peu
plus tard et
non pas forcément de bonnes retraites
donc il y a aussi cette inquiétude là du
fait de
la particularité de cette profession
j'ai vu que les syndicats annoncés 60%
de grève hier ils établaient plutôt sur
70 donc ils ont revu chiffre à la baisse
et les chiffres officiels 42% de grévise
dans le primaire c'est ça tout à fait 35
dans le secondaire tout à fait 35% dans
le secondaire
oui j'aurais pensé que ça allait être un
peu plus important quand même
c'est vrai que nous on a plus vu il y a
des lycées bloqués il y avait des lycées
bloqués ce matin à Paris alors c'est
toujours un peu
des lycéens mais les enseignants c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu étonnant de
voir je pensais enfin franchement
honnêtement je pensais qu'il y aurait
plus de d'enseignants en grève après on
va voir les chiffres définitifs
on aura peut-être des surprises mais oui
c'est un petit peu un peu étonnant 8
nous sommes en direct vous voyez ces
images à Paris avec ce cortège qui
devait s'élancer à 14 heures de la place
de République un public visiblement il a
du mal à avancer pour se diriger vers la
place de la Nation on va retrouver nos
envies spéciaux sur place mais il y a
beaucoup de monde c'est difficile
d'avoir du du réseau on parle avec
Sophie de parler des profs et des
étudiants qui et des lycéens qui
visiblement se mettent juste une
question si je suis parents aujourd'hui
je peux emmener mon enfant à l'école il
y a pas une obligation d'accueil dans
les mairies des mers comment ça se passe
oui oui tout à fait il y a beaucoup
d'écoles alors non pas forcément court
mais
oui il y a des écoles restent ouvertes
en fait donc normalement vous pouvez
vous avez pu même amener votre enfant à
l'école
ce matin voilà j'ai vu les ados partir
au lycée et alors souvent on leur a dit
de venir plus tard ne pas venir il y
avait pas forcément cours à 8h j'étais à
le dire mais à 9h oui on n'a pas eu de
on n'a pas eu de mots comme quoi il y
avait pas cours aujourd'hui donc
finalement après le problème des
enseignants c'est pas forcément des
enseignants qui font forcément grève
mais il y a beaucoup d'enseignants qui
n'ont tout simplement pas pu venir à
l'école aujourd'hui du fait des gaz de
transport tout simplement donc beaucoup
d'enseignants notamment en région
parisienne habitent en banlieue
sont moins chers donc forcément les
moyens d'habiter d'habiter à Paris et
c'est vrai que et c'est vrai qu'ils
n'ont pas pu venir prendre les
transports il y avait quand même pas mal
de métro qui marchaient quand même mais
les TER les trains de banlieue de marché
du mal et c'est vrai que Ben parfois les
enfants tout simplement n'ont pas le
droit enfin les cours à cause de ça les
profs une des principales forces
syndicales du pays c'est toujours pareil
les profs sont toujours aussi syndiqués
mobilisés les premiers à faire grève ou
c'est moins le cas oui mais c'est en
fait les syndicats sont très forts dans
l'enseignement il faut savoir que moi
souvent je demande aux enseignants mais
il disait tous syndiqués enfin comment
ça se passe et même si on est de droite
on est dans un syndicat de gauche par
exemple parce que forcément tous les
enseignements sont gauches c'est
vraiment des questions que tout le monde
se pose finalement il y a forcément des
enseignants qui sont pas la CGT non ils
m'ont dit mais même si on est pas
forcément dans les ces mêmes idées
politiques en fait on est obligé d'être
syndiqué pour avoir tout simplement
accès aux informations pour les
promotions pour les en fait c'est les
ces syndications extrêmement forts en
tout cas c'est le retour que j'ai et
souvent elles sont obligées de en fait
s'il ne se tiennent pas au courant via
les syndicats ils sont pas tellement
informés donc souvent et d'ailleurs il
se d'être peu informé on le voit souvent
on a les informations à la télé on voit
les informations dans le Parisien ou
dans le Figaro mais finalement on est on
n'est pas informés par notre ministère
ou bien on a les informations par les
syndicats donc nous les enseignants
sont pas forcément syndiqués au sens
propre du terme mais disons que ils sont
tous mis plus ou moins l'infini pour
être informés tout simplement de de des
salaires des vouloir parler aux profs
quel est leur état d'esprit est-ce qu'on
peut s'attendre à une grève qui dure ou
là c'est un coup d'essai puis on verra
demain il y aura tout le monde en classe
oui je pense qu'il y aura tout le monde
en classe demain mais c'est vrai qu'il y
a quand même un ras-le-bol ce que je
vois c'est que
ils sont lassés en fait là c'est par
toutes les réformes les futurs réformes
lacets des des promesses un peu de
revalorisation salariale et puis aussi
des problèmes vécu en classe
c'est vrai qu'on parlait de l'école
inclusive de de souvent ils doivent
accueillir des enfants handicapés en
classe pour souvent ils le vivent mal
parce qu'ils trouvent qu'ils n'ont pas
assez de moyens pour les accueillir des
classes surchargées parfois donc oui un
petit ras-le-bol un gros ras-le-bol même
et puis aussi le fait que c'est une
profession qui n'est pas très attractive
mal valorisée beaucoup de gens qui sont
partis et on a du mal à recruter on l'a
vu au mois de septembre avec les speed
dating donc oui alors c'est pas
forcément des profs en les formant à la
va-vite en plus c'est quelque chose
qu'on voyait souvent régulièrement ce
n'était pas complètement nouveau mais
c'est vrai de le voir comme ça
en images c'était assez frappant donc
oui il y a un ras-le-bol après est-ce
que ça va se cristalliser pour la
réforme des retraites je n'en sais rien
les manifs les manifestations et les
mouvements sociaux en général c'est
extrêmement difficile de prévoir la
suite
sur YouTube sur Le Figaro.fr cortège qui
semble un peu à l'arrêt visiblement
peu d'image et le leaders syndicaux ont
déjà parlé on va retrouver bientôt nos
envoyer sur Envoyer spéciaux sur place
qui nous explique ce qu'il se passe mais
pour l'instant avec Sophie Tarlé on
parle des profs aujourd'hui très
simplement les profs ils partent à quel
âge à la retraite
normalement c'est bah en fait ça dépend
ça dépend des
ça dépend de l'âge où on commence à
travailler ça dépend de
plutôt que les autres ou pas un régime
spécial pour l'épreuve 57 ans il me
semble
donner le chiffre exact mais mais ils
partent plutôt mais ce qu'on voit c'est
qu'ils veulent pas partir à 65 ans c'est
sûr ou 64 ans alors que bien souvent de
toute façon ils seront peut-être obligés
de travailler plus longtemps tout
simplement par pour avoir un taux plein
donc
parfois ils ont commencé tard parce que
là je devais pas à la retraite c'est
aussi on a commencé à travailler et
c'est pas des gens c'est des gens qui
ont fait des études forcément et qui qui
ont commencé plus tard à travailler
[Musique]
le lycée Talbot turgo
et oui donc avec bien l'intention de
mettre le enfin je voulais pas dire de
gros mots le bazar cet après-midi donc
c'est vrai que j'écoutais attentivement
les commentaires de Christophe Cornavin
et oui en effet
il y a quand même un risque en tout cas
ils étaient assez décidé ce matin à
mettre le bazar dans les dans les rues
fin d'après-midi
mais faire grève quand on est lycéens
c'est un peu facile on perd pas d'argent
là on bloque et puis c'est tout ce
qu'ils sont crédibles et lycéens dans
des périodes comme celle-ci non mais on
a déjà vu des manifs de lycéens pour les
grèves pour les pour la pour les
retraites
c'est vrai qu'en 95 par exemple ça
remonte un petit peu loin mais c'était
déjà pour pour cette raison là et les
jeunes avaient manifesté aussi donc
c'est c'est tout à fait plausible après
c'est vrai que en les interrogeant
devant devant glisser
c'était assez amusant de voir qu'il
disait on est contre la retraite à 70
ans enfin bon ils avaient pas tellement
suivi l'actualité ils étaient ils
disaient oui on manifeste aussi contre
parcoursup donc les propos étaient bons
pas toujours très très motivés et pas
toujours très informé mais mais puis
c'est toujours un petit peu même les
mêmes lycées qui sont bloqués c'est
toujours le lycées un peu de du centre
de l'Est parisien qui qui bloque leurs
établissements et pas toujours ça voilà
c'est c'est des ils vont manifester mais
évidemment pour la retraite ils sont
c'est un peu lointains pour eux
évidemment est-ce que les étudiants eux
sont mobilisés on le sait l'exemple
68 on en est très loin bien sûr mais
est-ce que ils peuvent finalement
déclencher quelque chose parce que les
syndicats étudiants pour l'instant on
n'entend pas trop parler ils ont quand
même appelé la page lunettes
et la voie lycéenne pour lycéen ont
appelé à manifester aujourd'hui et à
bloquer certains à bloquer les lycées ça
reste calme parce qu'évidemment c'est
pas c'est moins facile de mobiliser des
jeunes sur une réforme des retraites qui
évidemment un peu lointaine pour eux
mais il y a des étudiants il y a des
lycéens aujourd'hui dans les rues de
Paris et ailleurs dans les villes de
France qui sont mobilisés donc après je
dis pas que ça il y aura un mouvement
fou et que tous les étudiants sont
concernés mais il y a quand même oui les
syndicales étudiants et lycéens ont
clairement appelé à manifester
je vais recevoir dans un instant pour
vous succéder Sophie François-Xavier
bonjour je vous rappelle que nous sommes
en direct dans cette manifestation cette
manifestation qui pour l'instant semble
au point mort mais on va suivre tout ça
on a ces images en hauteur de la place
de la République qui est quand même très
fourni de ce qu'on voit pas très loin
une autre image du président de la
République lui il est en Espagne
figurez-vous chers Sophie il est en
train de prendre la parole pour
l'instant dans un discours qui concerne
ce sommet entre la France et l'Espagne
on écoute tout ça est-ce qu'on peut
avoir l'image on va dire le chef de
l'État voilà il est ici présent de la
République pour l'instant il est si
importante notre coopération a aussi été
forgé rappelons-le autour de la lutte
conjointe et victorieuse voilà le
terrorisme de la lutte conjoint sur les
territoires et on va discuter de tout ça
avec François Xavier Bourbon merci merci
de nous avoir expliqué tout ça
concernant l'épreuve les étudiants
dans un instant on a retrouvé des images
politique bien sûr parce que c'est
l'access se passe à peu près tous les
lacs coopération entre nos deux pays
suivant la manifestation de cet
après-midi beaucoup de monde place de la
République venez mon cher
François-Xavier
[Musique]
et la nécessité d'augmenter nos salaires
c'est une petite notice est-ce que vous
êtes prêts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
reprendre mes questions
de la République en Espagne alors il est
parti signer un traité d'amitié
franco-espagnol c'est une rencontre qui
était prévue de longue date au moins 6
mois on sait que ce genre de rendez-vous
diplomatique s'organise très longtemps
en amont et surtout on peut pas être
annulé à la dernière minute c'est les
syndicats qui ont choisi la date du 19
janvier sans sans voir qu'il y avait
cette rencontre qui était programmée à
Barcelone
c'est une
coïncidence fortuite je pousse le
curseur un peu plus loin
mon premier président de la République
n'est pas là 11 ministres sont avec lui
le ministre de l'intérieur était avec
lui est-ce que ça c'est pas un peu
particulier il pouvait pas rester en
France Gérald Darmanin alors que il peut
y avoir des débordements aujourd'hui que
les forces de l'ordre sont mobilisées ça
c'est étonnant alors il y a un ministre
qui était prévu pour pour Barcelone et
qui est qui on a demandé de rester en
France c'est le ministre du Travail
Olivier du soft c'est une façon de
signaler que le sujet du jour est avant
tout lié à la réforme des retraites on
laisse le l'un des ministres en tout cas
qui est concerné par ces manifestations
et pas un sujet sécuritaire donc Gérald
Darmanin le ministre de l'Intérieur est
à Barcelone c'est une façon de signaler
de la part du du gouvernement qu'on
regarde cette journée en France avant
tout comme une manifestation syndicale
en lien avec les retraites et pas du
tout un sujet sécuritaire d'accord bon
alors
ces images on y vient c'est un message
envoyé
au gouvernement c'est assez fort selon
vous pour le faire ou non faut pas
exagérer pour l'instant non non là on
est vraiment dans dans les pure de la
chorégraphie d'une contestation de
réforme des retraites c'est quelque
chose de tout à fait chorégraphié on
connaît on connaît les figures donc il y
a eu acte 1 première étape on va
l'annonce de la réforme des retraites
concertation présentation du projet de
loi réaction outrée des syndicats et des
oppositions ça c'était l'acte 1 Acte 2
ça commence aujourd'hui voilà c'est
assez la scène 1
la manifestation syndicale avec un
Français syndical uni dans toute la
France avec appel à la grève mais on est
encore que dans le la première étape du
bras de fer derrière l'enjeu pour les
syndicats c'est d'amplifier parce que le
gouvernement ne va pas dire ce soir
Emmanuel Macron en rentrant de Barcelone
oulala il y a du monde dans la rue je
retire mon projet c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe il y a effectivement du
monde ça engage un rapport de force les
syndicats vont revenir le voir en lui
disant
on a mis vraisemblablement alors là
Martinez parlait d'un million de
personnes plus d'un million de personnes
de la part des syndicats
et de la part de du gouvernement et
de ministre de ministère de l'Intérieur
combien en dessous du million en dessous
du milieu c'est-à-dire que c'est c'est
ça paraît anecdotique et effectivement
il y a toujours des écarts entre les
estimations de l'intérieur et les
estimations syndicales mais c'est aussi
de la part de chacun une façon d'entrer
dans le bras de fer les syndicats disons
énormément mobilisé quitte à grossir le
grossir le trait avec tout de même
une limite c'est ils doivent franchir le
cap qu'ils ont atteint aujourd'hui à la
prochaine manifestation donc il faut le
fixer au pour être fort par rapport au
gouvernement d'accord mais pas trop pour
ce que vous me dites c'est que c'est
comme quand on fait un premier film le
premier film c'est bien il faut
confirmer sur le deuxième voilà il faut
faire un bon score sur la première mais
faire encore mieux sur la deuxième alors
avec une nuance c'est que les noms de
place de cinéma vous pouvez les compter
ça vous avez les tickets vendus c'est là
c'est une estimation donc les syndicats
doivent fixer le le curseur assez haut
pour se présenter en position de force
face au gouvernement mais pas trop pour
pouvoir dépasser ce chiffre lors de la
prochaine manifestation honnêtement
François gavés est-ce que vous attendiez
à de telles images aujourd'hui avec
cette foule vous me dites oui non c'est
impressionnant ça allait pas non il y a
beaucoup de monde
donc là j'imagine qu'on va vraiment
parler du côté syndical de démonstration
de force réussie et appeler le
gouvernement à retirer son son projet de
loi voir enfin donc le le rapport de
force en tout cas la première la
première scène de l'acte 2 de la réforme
des retraites et en faveur des syndicats
ah donc ça ça m'intéresse
honnêtement c'est une bataille qui va
durer longtemps mais
là première bataille gagnée par les
syndicats en tout cas sur la force de
l'image pourquoi le gouvernement
n'arrive pas à convaincre si autant de
Français sont dans la rue ce ne sera
peut-être pas suffisant ce n'est
peut-être pas la majorité des français
même si les sondages disent que
visiblement les Français sont plutôt
contre cette réforme des retraites
pourquoi le gouvernement n'arrive pas à
convaincre là la réforme des retraites
on parle de maire des batailles mère des
réformes bon on est dans le symbole
absolu c'est à dire que on est plus du
tout dans les les considérations
techniques c'est plus plus personne
n'entend rien là on est dans un bras de
fer ou c'est extrêmement manichéen le
gouvernement dit on va faire la réforme
on ne reculera pas la rue dit il faut
retirer la réforme on reculera pas bon
c'est ce rapport de force qui il est
plus question de convaincre maintenant
c'est un bras de fer et il se remporte
en plusieurs étapes là la première étape
je lui ai en faveur des syndicats parce
qu'il y a effectivement beaucoup de
monde dans la rue c'est lié aussi au
front syndical Unis qui est assez rare
dans le dans le le monde du local de
voir tous les syndicats derrière le ça
faisait ça faisait 12 ans mais même
au-delà avant c'est c'est aussi très
très rare en 95 de mémoire les grandes
grève de 95 qui essayent de reproduire
les syndicats aujourd'hui une des images
fortes de ces grèves là ça avait été la
poignée de main entre Louis Vianney qui
était le patron de la CGT à l'époque de
Mark Blondel le patron de FO à l'époque
deux centrales syndicales qui étaient
historiquement hier bien sûr
on le sait entre la CGT et Force
Ouvrière donc le l'unité syndicale c'est
vraiment le donc c'est le turbo de la
mobilisation syndicale là on voit que ça
fonctionnait aujourd'hui l'enjeu pour
les syndicats c'est de la maintenir et
l'enjeu pour le gouvernement c'est de la
briser et pour la briser et bien il faut
réussir à décrocher à celle si possible
la CFDT et pour ça il y a quelques
billes en poche
mais elle Macron c'est pas lancé dans la
réforme des retraites
bi en tête
il a gardé quelques quelques concessions
éventuellement à faire au syndicat via
la discussion parlementaire à
l'Assemblée nationale si la bataille
d'amendement laisse la place ce que
veulent mener les insoumis laisse de la
place pour discuter éventuellement
d'ouverture mais le toute la
chorégraphie maintenant qui va se qui va
se dérouler c'est une sorte de phase de
négociation deuxième étape de
négociation de discussion quand je vois
les sondages je des sondages qui
demandent aux Français êtes-vous pour ou
contre la réforme des retraites plus le
temps passe plus ça va plus les vagues
successives de sondage arrive et plus
les Français sont contre gouvernement
est incapable de faire comprendre cette
réforme le gouvernement est incapable de
convaincre
pourquoi mais alors c'est c'est
impossible de vendre une réforme des
retraites
vous pouvez pas susciter de
l'enthousiasme populaire avec une
réforme des retraites non qui vous
demande de travailler donc de toute
façon la bataille avec de plus en plus
de français ce qui se laissent
convaincre par cet argument qui est
simplissime mais qui
est utilisé par le gouvernement on vit
plus longtemps on doit travailler plus
longtemps pourquoi les français si c'est
si simple que ça le gouvernement répète
le répète le répète si c'est simple ok
ça pourquoi les Français ne comprennent
pas et parce que le gouvernement est
entré dans la réforme des retraites en
ayant déjà perdu la bataille de
l'opinion ça ça peut pas s'améliorer
sauf circonstances particulières les
retournements d'opinion c'est très rare
il y en a eu un spectaculaire sur un
autre sujet c'est le nucléaire ça
faisait des années que les Français
étaient opposés au nucléaire
vous l'avez dit ça a pris des années sur
les retraites la seule chose qui
pourrait faire basculer ou provoquer un
basculement de l'opinion ce serait ce
qu'on a pu observer pendant les la crise
des gilets jaunes c'est une dérive du
mouvement ou des blocages qui
perturberaient la vie du pays qui
vraiment j'aimerais les Français parce
que pour l'instant on est encore sur une
discussion qui consiste à dire il va
falloir travailler deux ans de plus donc
le tout tout le côté sucré de la réforme
le ratrate à 1200 euros enfin tout ce
que le l'exécutif a essayé d'apporter
comme compensation sociale pour amortir
un peu la dureté de la réforme
pour l'instant ça n'a pas encore atteint
l'opinion et en plus sont des mesures
qui sont assez techniques
voilà même si tout a été simplifié en
comparaison de la réforme de 2019 et
Emmanuel Macron tout a été simplifié
mais il y a quand même quelque chose qui
s'est produit après la présentation de
cette réforme
beaucoup de monde a été voir sur le sur
internet le site France Connect combien
il leur restait de trimestres à cotisés
à quel âge il pourrait partir à la
retraite on a un super simulateur fait
par le feed data je vous conseille
française allons plutôt sur le sur
celui-ci et en réalité tout le monde a
une mauvaise surprise on se sent
réalisant qu'il avait qu'il allait
falloir encore travailler longtemps
partir à la retraite très tard et pour
un montant pas forcément très élevé ça
c'était le premier effet de la réforme
Touraine
en 2013 on s'en souvient qui allongé
progressivement la durée de cotisation
donc les Français ont réalisé en 2023 ce
qui allait leur arriver avec la réforme
de 2013 et on leur présente une réforme
qui va encore durcir ces conditions ça
va s'accélérer voilà et donc ça ne
pouvait pas ça ne pouvait pas emporter
l'adhésion populaire et d'ailleurs au
sein du gouvernement
en coulisses on s'en cache pas c'est une
réforme financière qui vise équilibrer
le système et on emporte pas
l'enthousiasme des foules avec une
réforme financière qui demande de
travailler plus longtemps voilà c'est
quelque chose d'acté est-ce que cette
stratégie parce que c'est vrai le
gouvernement ne fait que très peu de
faux sanglants en disant mais si elle
est bonne pour vous assez peu finalement
bon sur certains points un seuil à 1200
euros etc mais il est assez clair en
disant on n'a pas le choix et il faut
faire des efforts est-ce que cette
stratégie peut durer est-ce qu'il faut
pas justement aller dans peut-être plus
de douceur prendre les Français par la
main leur dire ok on fait ça mais on
vous donne ça de l'autre côté pour
essayer de les convaincre ils ont déjà
essayé avant mais ils ont déjà essayé
c'est ce qu'ils essayent de faire depuis
le début en mettant en avant les mesures
dites suc
donc c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont
essayé mais qui n'est pas passé dans
l'opinion encore bon nous verrons mais
encore une fois on est vraiment dans
dans la chorégraphie classique d'une
réforme des retraites ce qui est
intéressant à observer à regarder dans
ce dans ce type d'événement
c'est s'il y a un élément qui sort de
cette chorégraphie classique or
qu'est-ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui que
autour des manifestants traditionnels
s'il y a des bataillons syndicaux se
greffent un halo de personnes qui n'ont
pas l'habitude de se mobiliser
commerçant vraisemblablement personne du
privé aussi qui est les transports les
profs
les bataillons ordinaires mais le autour
de ces bataillons ordinaires et en train
de se greffer un nouveau Halo et c'est
ça qui avait fait la différence en 95
c'est à dire que les salariés du privé
avaient rejoint dans la grève vous ne
pouvez pas aller travailler mais
mécaniquement rejoint les grévistes en
95 et que peu petit à petit l'opinion
s'était mis à soutenir massivement les
grévistes
est-ce que le gouvernement
efface un problème insolite qui est un
désintérêt une nouvelle vision de voir
le travail est-ce que ça dans les
ministères on se dit puis le covid
depuis l'apparition du télétravail les
gens ont envie de travailler et ça on
peut pas aller quoi
il y a même des réflexions qui vont qui
vont bien au-delà de ces seules
questions du télétravail de l'impact du
covid la société des loisirs des 35
heures bien au-delà qui qui porte sur un
basculement de civilisation alors là là
on est on passe dans un autre monde et
c'est parce que philosophique là voilà
on passe dans la philosophie où
[Musique]
la société capitaliste aujourd'hui soit
matérialiste
aurait perdu en transcendant ses soirées
à la recherche sur d'idéal
qu'une génération une génération
trouve donc la défense de
l'environnement par exemple mais en gros
la société serait en recherche d'idéale
et le travail répondrait plus à cette à
cette recherche d'idéal bon là on part
assez loin peut-être pas ça faire des
dessus parce que c'est
au gouvernement on est obligé de faire
attention à cet endroit il s'inquiète en
tout cas sur le sur la vision du travail
que véhicule les manifestants c'est à
dire que le travail serait perçu comme
une commune purge j'ai pas comme un
facteur d'épanouissement bon c'est un
peu compliqué de vendre le travail comme
un lieu de réalisation de soi-même quand
vous devez faire face à de l'inflation
parler et donc à des salaires qui
provoquent des pertes de pouvoir d'achat
bien sûr si je parle de chiffres
qu'on voit ces images impressionnantes
quand même de la place de la République
on ne sait pas c'est toujours pareil
c'est cette foule est très concentrée ou
si elle déborde dans les rues adjacentes
nous auront des chiffres plus définitifs
dans la dans la fin de la journée partir
de combien de personnes dans la rue
cette journée sera une réussite et le
gouvernement pourra s'inquiéter un petit
peu
les syndicats l'ont dit eux-mêmes on en
parlait tout à l'heure c'est un million
c'était le c'était le cap la dernière
référence c'était donc c'était 2018 la
dernière réforme des retraites les
syndicats avaient revendiqué 1 million
cinq donc il devrait vraisemblablement
ce soir annoncé un chiffre autour de 1
million 500 000
manifestants dit une fois encore l'enjeu
étant de réussir à le dépasser lors de
la prochaine manifestation donc ils vont
décider la date la date ce soir
qu'est-ce qui est le plus marquant
beaucoup de monde dans la rue les images
comme ça des milliers de personnes
peut-être d'un million de personnes qui
défilent ou un blocage du pays je pense
évidemment en transport je pense au
raffinerie je pense aux profs avec des
parents qui ne peuvent pas faire l'école
qu'est-ce qui j'aimerais le plus le
gouvernement c'est les blocages il y a
pas de aucune aucune hésitation sur le
sur ça c'est vraiment les blocages parce
que les blocages mais c'est de la perte
de PIB c'est un impact sur la croissance
sur le sur le
même le fonctionnement du pays donc
c'est les blocages qu'on redoute le plus
le pays mais là
tout ça va dépendre des stratégies
syndicales ça se décide en inter
syndicale avec donc ce France syndical
uni toute la question parce que tout a
été pris en compte en fait de tous les
côtés je voulais vous faire le film
allez-y bon alors Conseil des ministres
23 Conseil des ministres du 23
présentation de la réforme qui part
directement au Parlement où là de voir
être examiné en 21 jours donc le 23
c'est mardi prochain voilà le mercredi
prochain le 23 c'est lundi d'ailleurs
c'est lundi quoi le 23
normalement 23 janvier présentation du
conseil de des projets définitifs voilà
en Conseil des ministres
il part au Parlement au Parlement il y a
21 jours pour les pour l'étudier avant
qu'ils partent au cinéma il y a le
procédure parlementaire un peu complexe
là l'article 47 1
études accéléré pour éviter les
batailles d'amendement et que le texte
dure trop longtemps pourquoi parce que
derrière c'est au bout de ce délai d'une
vingtaine de jours vous tombez sur quoi
il vous le demande les vacances de
février vacances d'hiver
il y a une petite semaine au ski prévu
il faut y aller voilà et donc
mécaniquement et ben les mobilisations
pendant trois semaines parce que c'est
des semaines tournantes sur trois zones
vous avez trois semaines durant
lesquelles la mobilisation va être plus
compliqué d'où l'enjeu pour les
syndicats de soit parier sur une montée
en puissance du mouvement très rapide et
très forte c'est à dire reprogrammer dès
ce soir une mobilisation pour la semaine
prochaine avec
trois énormes manifestations avec un
million de personnes dans la rue voilà
et puis parce que l'enjeu aussi c'est de
peser sur les débats qui vont se
dérouler au Parlement bien sûr donc
vacances de février
le texte reviendra du Sénat et là à
nouveau alors je récapitule j'ai entendu
que si les députés ne se mettaient pas
d'accord ils partaient sans amendement
aussi
alors c'est l'article 47 1 qui est
49-3 il est pas toujours très clair que
je veux l'article 47 ans que dit-il je
veux pas perdre vos spectateurs c'est
assez compliqué ça les intéresse j'en
suis persuadé qu'il réagissez si
François-Xavier n'est pas clair sur le
financement ou si je me trompe parce que
c'est assez technique
la réforme des retraites va être passée
dans le cadre du plfsr qui est le projet
de loi de finance rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale sur lequel le
gouvernement peut activer l'article 49-3
sur le faire passer en force mais il ne
veut pas utiliser cet article parce que
pas surtout les
jeunes qui sont relativement budget il y
a 49-3 illimité voilà ce qui n'est pas
le cas sur l'ensemble des autres textes
il y en a qu'un pour l'ensemble des
autres textes donc économiser à 49-3
pour pouvoir faire passer éventuellement
d'autres textes on va laisser les autres
textes de côté on va se concentrer sur
les sur les retraites
cette réforme des retraites elle est
étudiée dans le cadre d'un
loi budgétaire voilà sur lequel il y a
des 49-3 à répétition possible mais le
gouvernement ne veut pas utiliser de
49-3 pour ne pas mettre de l'huile sur
le feu et venir grossir les rangs des
manifestants qui sont déjà très fournis
comme on le voit sur les images le
symbole politique la rue contre le
Gouvernement l'Assemblée contre le
gouvernement avec un 49 obligatoire
voilà difficile de faire passer une
réforme ça fait qu'on est arrivé le
gouvernement a trouvé des alliés à
l'Assemblée LR qui sont prêts à voter la
réforme donc pour éviter le 49.3 on va
passer par l'article 47 1 qui raccourcit
l'examen du du texte la durée d'examen
au Parlement normalement c'est c'est
éliminer illimité jusqu'à ce que tous
les articles soient
s'il y a tous les amendements que quand
déposer la France insoumise ça peut
durer une plante et si ça dure si ça
dure très longtemps le risque c'est que
la contestation dure elle aussi très
longtemps et que vous bloquez le pays
pendant un deux trois mois enfin je vais
et quand vous bloquez un pays où vous
mettez un pays sous tension pendant
aussi longtemps
le rapport de force tourne pas forcément
en faveur du gouvernement donc on va
dire article 47 1 procédure
toute l'actualité socialisée sur la
réforme des retraites pendant trois mois
il se passe au gouvernement on arrive
pas à parler d'autre chose et
c'est évidemment très négatif pour lui
voilà donc série d'aller-retours et au
bout du compte on arrive à un délai
d'une cinquantaine de jours pour pouvoir
faire adopter cette réforme des
retraites par le Parlement donc le 10
avril si j'ai bien calculé 50 jours non
le 10 mars oui plutôt mars
il pourrait y avoir une réforme de
retraite adoptée en tout cas votée par
le Parlement voté par le Parlement et là
vous opposez la légitimité de
l'assemblée des élus la légitimité
politique à la légitimité sociale
bataille de légitimité et du côté du
gouvernement Parian pour que la
contestation s'essouffle
c'est moi qui mets souvent
c'est compliqué mais si on regarde étape
par étape il faut pas il faut pas en
fait cette journée ces images qu'on voit
il faut pas les lire en statique il faut
les voir en dynamique comme les sondages
c'est à dire qu'il va falloir les juger
au regard de la prochaine ça c'est un
point de départ et au point de départ on
a une forte mobilisation que les
syndicats vont appeler à simplifié et
donc la semaine prochaine
vraisemblablement on aura bis repetita
j'en ai de grève et manifestation alors
avec ensuite il y a plusieurs figures là
on est dans des manifestations dans
toute la France oui mais ensuite vous
pouvez avoir la manifestation syndicale
à Paris ou là si vous mettez si vous
mettez 800000 personnes un million dans
la rue à Paris pour changer de braquet
vous passez voilà une autre étape
syndicat et le gouvernement aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il y a la moindre chance
honnêtement de faire fléchir un syndicat
et on pense évidemment à la CFDT alors
non
tant que le report de l'âge légal de
départ est maintenu à 64 ans
l'enjeu pour le gouvernement c'est pas
faire accepter à la CFDT ça parce que
à son dernier congrès Laurent Berger a
reçu un mandat clair de ce militant qui
était de refuser tout report de l'âge
légal donc le cette question là c'est
une porte fermée le gouvernement
n'obtiendra pas de Laurent Berger qu'il
se rallie à sa réforme en revanche avec
des concessions parallèles sur d'autres
sujets l'emploi des seniors la
pénibilité il peut obtenir non pas une
adhésion mais en tout cas
[Musique]
certaines formes de
neutralité ou de mise en retrait ou en
tout cas Laurent Berger ne dira jamais
d'accord à cette réforme il pourrait
dire bon nous on appelle plus à
descendre dans la rue voilà mais à
partir du moment où il se retire du
front syndical uni la mécaniquement vous
descendez de vous descendez d'un étage
dans la mobilisation quelle est la plus
grande bataille pour le gouvernement la
rue les syndicats ou l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que aujourd'hui
mon temps que les
députés les républicains devraient
pourraient voter cette réforme est-ce
qu'ils vont le faire est-ce que le
gouvernement on a l'assurance
c'est après c'est des il peut y avoir
deux trois petites choses à discuter à
négocier à l'Assemblée nationale mais
l'accord ça a l'air d'être topé il peut
y avoir des défections à droite à gauche
mais le disons que la majorité pour
faire voter une réforme des retraites a
l'air d'être verrouillée ou en tout cas
verrouillable le plus gros le plus gros
enjeu c'est la rue évidemment c'est la
rue et l'opposition syndicale c'est les
blocages qui devait s'installer sur la
durée dans le pays le vrai enjeu c'est
ça le
[Musique]
ce qui est il faut bien comprendre que
quand Emmanuel Macron se lance dans
cette dans cette réforme des retraites
sa difficulté par rapport aux autres
formes qui ont pu être mise en oeuvre
sous d'autres d'autres quinquennat c'est
que lui il avait deux fronts sur
lesquels
de feront à aborder affront politique
avec des alliés à trouver et un front
syndical avec des adversaires à
affronter sur le front politique les
alliés les a trouvés
erikiotti approuve la réforme des
retraites sur le France syndical les
adversaires sont là dans la rue
aujourd'hui et c'est eux qui doivent
maintenant qui doit maintenant affronter
et en tout cas c'est forcé de de
contenir dans la montée en puissance de
leur mouvement est-ce que cette alliance
aujourd'hui entre les syndicats et les
partis de gauche
peut durer ça c'est intéressant les
leaders de politiques de la gauche sont
acceptés dans cette magnifique
[Musique]
alors qu'on va les images en direct
d'Emmanuel Macron à Barcelone et
évidemment on imagine que une question
qui sera posée sur cette journée de
mobilisation et on l'écoutera à ce
moment-là je vous laisse poursuivre
François-Xavier est-ce que
la grammaire syndicale est compliqué et
complexe aujourd'hui c'est une
manifestation syndicale à la paix à
l'appel des organisations syndicales
dans laquelle les partis politiques
peuvent venir se joindre mais vous
noterez bien qu'il n'était pas dans le
carré de tête le carré de tête qui est
un peu le le
char d'ouverture du défilé était composé
uniquement des des leaders syndicaux les
leaders politiques sont renvoyés à
l'arrière en accompagnement il y a
manifestations des de la France
insoumise samedi
spécifiquement contre les contre les
retraites mais vous n'avez pas vu
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui était à Marseille
il me semble à Marseille vous vous
l'avez pas vu et vous n'avez pas vu les
leaders politiques défilés main dans la
main avec les leaders syndicaux c'est
quelque chose
l'indépendance syndicale c'est quelque
chose auquel ils sont tous très attachés
il veut pas ils ne veulent pas prendre
le risque de la récupération politique
et à côté vous avez des leaders
politiques qui font tout pour la
récupération politique parce que
une foule comme ça c'est pas éléphant
qui va la mettre dans la rue samedi je
suis prêt à prendre les paris que vous
n'allez pas retrouver mais elle est
fille et au-delà de LFI la nups
j'aimerais bien pouvoir
apparaître en tête de cortège et
apparaître comme leader d'une d'une
telle vague populaire c'est pas le c'est
pas le cas mais ça les les syndicats
font énormément attention à ce que ça
n'arrive pas Emmanuel Macron et
Barcelone et on lui pose une question
sur la retraite
dans l'oreille le principe même d'une
démocratie et qu'en vertu de notre
Constitution le droit de manifester
puisse s'exercer comme il s'exerce dans
toutes les démocraties de notre
continent et ailleurs et je fais
confiance aux organisateurs de ces
manifestations pour que cette expression
légitime de désaccord puisse se faire
sans créer trop de désagréments pour
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes et
évidemment sans débordement ni violence
ni dégradation
je pense qu'il y a comme vous le dites
dans une démocratie des règles et un bon
fonctionnement il faut que les choses
soient dites au moment où les choix
démocratiques sont faits et à l'élection
présidentielle qui s'est tenue somme
toute il n'y a que quelques mois et aux
élections législatives qui ne se sont
tenues y compris qu'il n'y a quelques
mois les choses ont été dites clairement
elles ont ensuite été négociées dans un
temps que nous avons laissé avec les
forces syndicales et patronales nous
rentrons maintenant dans le temps de la
proposition du gouvernement elle va
donner lieu à un travail démocratique
parlementaire qui permettra à toutes les
forces politiques à l'Assemblée au Sénat
s'exprimer
d'enrichir le projet et de pouvoir aller
au terme d'une réforme qui est une
réforme qui a donc été démocratiquement
présentée validé
qui est une réforme surtout juste et
responsable et il suffit de regarder
partout ailleurs en Europe et de voir
que la France
c'est un peu décalé et que si nous
voulons être juste entre les générations
et sauver notre système par répartition
nous devons faire cette réforme dans des
pays qui vivent de plus en plus
longtemps où nous avons créé des
systèmes juste efforts qui reposent sur
l'égalité entre les générations
des moments où vous avez
de moins en moins d'actifs et de plus en
plus de retraités si vous voulez que le
pacte entre les générations soit justes
il faut procéder à cette réforme et donc
nous le ferons avec respect sprit de
dialogue mais détermination et esprit de
responsabilité
pour faire la réforme des retraites
et en plus ont plus accorder ce crédit
que lors de la présidentielle c'était la
réforme que tout le monde comprenait on
sait qu'il est en train en campagne très
tard que c'était parfois un peu flou sur
ses propositions alors ça c'était clair
oui c'est la seule la seule proposition
qui a été identifiée clairement par les
électeurs dans son programme et donc
c'est ça qui l'invoque la légitimité
démocratique il a été investi par les
électeurs par le par le pays pour faire
cette réforme alors en face on a beau
jeu de démonter l'argument en expliquant
c'est ce qu'on entend beaucoup
au sein de la nupesse qui l'a surtout
été élu pour que Marine Le Pen ne soit
pas présente mais bon à cette élection
présidentielle il y a eu ce qui serait
aussi bien c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un
rejet derrière Le Pen qui s'est traduit
aussi dans les urnes mais c'est un des
volets du bras de fer donc il y a la
légitimité politique que revendique
Emmanuel Macron à côté et puis il y a la
légitimité de la rue que revendique les
syndicats aujourd'hui avec cette cette
manifestation et sans aucun doute c'est
ces prochains cortèges qu'ils vont
organiser dans les les jours semaines
qui viennent merci beaucoup
François-Xavier Moreau merci d'être venu
nous voir pile au moment le service
politique qui est là puis le moment où
le président de la République s'est
exprimé depuis Barcelone on va avoir
François de lettras ce qui nous parlera
de la question des transports dans un
instant d'abord on va voir Timothée
delhayme Timothée vous êtes sur place
vous êtes aux alentours de la place de
la République est-ce que ce cortège
s'est mis en marche
oui Thibault ce cortège s'est mis en
marche nous on a enfin réussi à résoudre
les problèmes de connexion il faut le
dire qu'il y a énormément de monde ici
et bien donc le réseau apparaît saturé
comme c'est le cas lors de ce genre
d'événement pour l'instant nous sommes
sur le boulevard Voltaire le boulevard
Voltaire parce qu'un deuxième axe a été
ouvert c'est ce que nous confiait un CRS
à l'instant le cortège principal qui se
situe boulevard du Temple un petit peu
derrière mais voilà énormément de monde
et c'est la raison pour laquelle et bien
beaucoup de monde également sur ce
boulevard Voltaire ou nous nous trouvons
il faut dire que beaucoup de monde 50000
à 80 000 personnes sont attendues ici la
manifestation qui a pris un petit peu de
retard le début du cortège a été annoncé
le départ du cortège était annoncé à 14h
ça a pris du retard mais en tous les cas
ici
cela le le pas lent mais assuré de ce
cortège se maintient avec cette marge
vers la place de la de la Nation pour
l'instant en tous les cas pas de pas de
heure là où nous nous trouvons beaucoup
de pancartes évidemment les manifestants
qui redouble d'un ventivité vous
écoutiez Emmanuel Macron à l'instant et
bien le chef de l'État qui a bien sûr
élastique des manifestants Emmanuel
Macron président des patrons on va plier
ta réforme à ton à ton lit sur certains
slogans 62 ans ça dépasse les bornes et
il également écrit sur les sur les
pancartes voilà les manifestants qui
continuent en tous les cas leur marche
vers la place de la Nation dans une
ambiance pour l'instant assez calme
merci beaucoup et Timothée de l'amoureux
de l'endroit dans un instant Vincent
roseron qui lui aussi est sur place
d'abord j'accueille François de lettrage
bonjour François bonjour journaliste au
Figaro Magazine évidemment spécialiste
des transports François les syndicats de
transport sont évidemment en première
ligne
comme souvent c'est eux qui mènent la
lutte ceux qui sont
comment on dit
devant les wagons la locomotive
en première ligne alors pourquoi
imaginez que vous ayez une petite
entreprise une petite PME à Mâcon avec
avec 10 personnes qui fait la grève ou à
Chalon-sur-Saône ou à Bar-le-Duc
il y a aucune il y aura aucune résonance
nationale
imaginez que ça soit l'entrepôt d'Amazon
en Bourgogne qui fasse grève c'est déjà
un peu plus gros on en parlera un peu
plus mais imaginez que ça soit les
infirmières sur le plan national et donc
là ça a une résidence résonance énorme
et en termes de transport on est face à
de très grosses entreprises très
syndiquées et ça concerne tout le monde
et comme c'est comme ce sont des jobs
transversaux
regardez si nous deux on fait la grève
parce qu'on n'a pas des métiers
transversaux en revanche si les
anesthésistes font la grève dans un
hôpital l'hôpital ne peut plus tourner
ah donc il y a des métiers qui sont plus
importants que d'autres et qui sont des
roisés
et le deuxième phénomène c'est qu'on ne
se rend pas compte
à quel point le transport public
transporte de monde on l'oublie je vais
vous donner quelques chiffres tout
simple
à Lyon les TCL transportent 775
000 personnes par jour
775000 à Lyon à Lyon à Paris les autobus
transportent 3 millions et demi de
personnes par jour rien que les autobus
le métro c'est 4 millions
le Transilien c'est encore plus donc
chaque jour par exemple en Île-de-France
il y a 10 millions de personnes qui sont
transportés par le transport public donc
le transport public c'est quelque chose
de phénoménal et je vais vous donner un
petit exemple en province aussi la ligne
en Lorraine qui est une des limites les
plus fréquentées
dans les années 70 ça transperne 12000
personnes par jour donc vous vous rendez
compte des chiffres qu'on a en transport
public donc ça veut dire que le
transport à partir du moment oui oui il
y a un échauffement avec le transport ça
a une résonance à la fois politique et
pratique qui sont phénoménales d'où la
force
de la grève dans les transports je
comprends bon c'est c'est historique ça
a toujours été le cas est-ce que les
leaders syndicaux ont toujours la main
la CGT surtout est faux Sud drive
ont-ils la main sur la base parce qu'on
se souvient ce qui s'est passé à Noël et
ça nous a un peu surpris quoique
je vais vous rappeler quelque chose
Guillaume Pepin l'ancien patron de la
SNCF nous avait dit dans une réunion de
presse vous allez voir le paysage
syndical va changer pourquoi parce qu'on
a énormément de gens qui partent à la
retraite qui est qui étaient les gens
d'après-guerre qui avait fondé le
mouvement syndical à la SNCF ces gens-là
partant on engage beaucoup beaucoup de
jeunes et donc le paysage va changer et
ben il s'est totalement trompé parce que
les jeunes ont adopté l'ADN de
l'entreprise et l'ADN syndicale de
l'entreprise alors on a une c'est à dire
qu'on arrive à la SNCF même si on n'est
pas syndiqué
alors on le devient plus pour un
syndicat réformiste que pour un syndicat
extrémiste genre Sud Rail et encore que
mais ce sont des entreprises fortement
syndiquées d'accord allez on retrouve
Vincent roseron il est sur place on
continue à parler de des transports avec
François de lettrage Vincent vous êtes
éloigné un peu à si vous m'entendez j'ai
vu que vous avez fait un petit un petit
geste vous êtes éloigné parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde et qui dit beaucoup de
monde
expliquez-moi ce que vous voyez ce qu'il
y a autour de vous et j'ai l'impression
que les gens sont bloqués place de la
République sur les images qu'on reçoit
non
exactement alors faut être tout à fait
honnête ça fait deux heures et demi que
je suis arrivé place de la République la
première fois et les gens qui sont ici
ont peut-être avancé de 100 mètres à
priori je pense mais effectivement pour
le moment la manipulation est bloquée de
ce côté-là en tout cas par son axe
principal on va dire la manifestation
qui devait rejoindre République à
Bastille une nation
et voilà François de lettraz vous avez
vu il y a trop de monde dans ces
manifestations on a perdu Vincent rose
on va le retrouver évidemment je sais
qu'il fait tout pour pouvoir nous donner
toutes les informations depuis la place
de la République
on dit des blocages pendant la grève
ils auront moins d'impact qu'avant
vraiment l'apparition du télétravail
c'est vrai ou pas
durant un jour
comme la expliqué notre collègue
quelques secondes risque de recommencer
plusieurs fois le télétravail ça va
quand c'est de temps en temps et puis il
y a plein de métiers où le télétravail
n'est pas possible regarder nous deux
regardez les caissières dans les
magasins regarde il y a mille métiers où
le télétravail n'est pas possible alors
j'ai vu qu'il y avait 37% des Français
qui avaient un accès au télétravail
ça c'est grâce au
covides se sont adaptées
est-ce que les syndicats et je voudrais
revenir à ça
ont encore du poids dans les entreprises
de transport je voudrais parler François
de ce qui s'est passé à Noël avec les
contrôleurs les contrôleurs sont entrés
en grève sans l'accord sans la démarche
des syndicats sans l'appui des syndicats
pourquoi parce que les centrales
syndicales l'avaient déposé des prêts à
ville grève
elle n'avait pas donné d'ordre de grève
et donc les contrôleurs ont profité de
ces préavis de grève qui avait été
déposées pour eux-mêmes faire grève de
manière spontanée vous voyez on est dans
une certaine ambiguïté mais il est vrai
qu'avec les réseaux sociaux on a parfois
des des conflits qui démarrent sans que
les syndicats n'en soit la tête d'accord
ça veut dire que il y a une gilet
jauneisation du de la manifestation des
mouvements sociaux pourtant je croyais
que les syndicats c'était justement leur
faire de l'an c'était là où ils étaient
le plus fort dans les entreprises de
transport mais là ils sont fait déborder
par les contrôleurs il y a eu un
ras-le-bol
il y a eu ras-le-bol naturel des
contrôleurs parce que leur métier a
beaucoup changé que c'est moins facile
qu'avant enfin etc et donc il y a eu ils
se sont parlés entre eux et ça ça a
débouché à ça pour une pour une
entreprise comme les SNCF ou la RATP
c'est très embêtant c'est des choses
comme ça parce que c'est ingérable c'est
compliqué c'est on dit c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure les contrôleurs
c'est un job transversal s'il y a pas de
contrôleurs dans un seul contrôleur dans
un TGV le TGV peut pas rouler donc vous
voyez c'est il a autre autant de poids
que le machinisme une dernière question
avant de vous libérer mon cher François
les régimes spéciaux on sait qu'en 2019
les syndicats et
employés des entreprises de transport
faisait grève pour qu'on ne touche pas à
leur régime spéciaux ce n'est pas le cas
alors on ne touche pas au régime
spéciaux et pourtant ils sont dans la
dans la dans les manifestations et c'est
intéressant parce que les Français
étaient contre les régimes spéciaux ils
ont l'air d'être plutôt contre cette
fois la réforme des retraites c'est à
dire qu'à l'époque il voulait qu'on
balaye les régimes faisceau donc ils
étaient plutôt contre ces employés des
transports à rester assez discret quand
même là dans la période qui vient alors
ils sont discrètes pour une raison toute
simple c'est que plus personne à la SNCF
par exemple n'est engagée aujourd'hui et
aura droit au régime spécial demain donc
c'est c'est quelque chose qui va mourir
doucement avec le départ à la retraite
des gens et leur décès plus tard donc
tous les nouveaux entrants de la SNCF
non pas droit au régime spécial c'est
déjà le cas donc c'est pour ça qu'on en
parle moins puisque c'est un régime
vieillissant
spéciaux à 30 ans 40 ans c'est long
encore ouais mais bon c'est le temps
qu'il faut pour que le pour que les
choses se fassent il faut prendre du
temps dans les entreprises de transport
merci François de lettrage rejoins tout
de suite Timothée delhem sur place
Timothée
alors ce qu'on va faire on cherche
François c'est vous vous laissez partir
et je vais accueillir dans un instant
Marie visola rédactrice en chef du
service économie du Figaro allez on met
les images en plein écran on essaye
d'écouter un peu l'ambiance et dans un
instant Marie est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour on se prend bienvenue sur Radio
France
[Musique]
bonjour Marie liso bonjour
du Figaro bon c'est une journée
historique ou non parce qu'il y a du
monde ça fait longtemps qu'on nous en
parle de cette grande mobilisation après
la réélection d'Emmanuel Macron c'est le
jour oui c'est le jour et puis on le
voit sur les visages effectivement il y
a du monde journée noire c'était un peu
l'interrogation qu'on avait en amont
cette journée de mobilisation il y a les
petits à voir du monde il y avait une
vraie incertitude on savait pas où on
allait aujourd'hui et puis bah là les
images que vous nous montrez depuis ce
matin le confirme il y a du monde alors
les images vous avez raison Marie on a
des images
c'est assez impressionnant c'est jamais
si ça déborde dans les rues mais surtout
on a les chiffres de ce matin en région
ils sont plutôt bons qui sont plutôt
bons alors vous avez raison les images
dans le reste de Paris je sais pas si
vous êtes baladé moi j'ai fait un petit
tour ce matin il y a personne
l'autre côté de Paris est quand même
assez calme alors effectivement c'est la
journée où on fait une Focus sur le
trajet de la manifestation oui il y a du
monde à Paris où il y a du monde en
région il y a beaucoup de monde à
Marseille où on manifeste sous les
slogans à la retraite avant l'arthrite
il y a du monde partout
on sera largement au-delà du million ce
sera gros succès si on passe le million
et demi bon enfin voilà
le jeu des chiffres entre les syndicats
et ceux de la police
nous ferons jouer encore entre mes
réalités
de faire un peu de pédagogie on va
suivre évidemment c'est ces images mais
pour tout vous dire moi j'ai quand même
du mal à y comprendre pourtant vous
savez que tous les jours je lis vos
papiers vos articles
aussi je peux croire les coupes des
journalistes qui ont des économistes les
hommes et des femmes politiques et j'ai
l'impression à chaque fois que j'en
entends et j'en écoute un bien il a
raison et puis cinq minutes après
j'entends un autre qui dit totalement
autre chose et une convaincre c'est très
difficile de se faire une idée et est-ce
que les Français qui sont dans la rue
ceux qui nous regardent comprennent eux
de ce qui se passe vraiment alors
c'est intéressant ce que vous soulevez
comme comme question c'est à dire que
vous dites que l'un puis l'autre arrive
à vous convaincre vous devez écouter des
politiques beaucoup quand même oui c'est
vrai alors effectivement là
il y a des économistes de tout de tous
les bords les uns vous parleront plus du
recules de l'âge de la retraite les
autres vous parleront plus de la durée
de cotisation certains se concentreront
sur mes oui mais ça protège les
carrières longues donc on se concentrera
sur des aspects vu comme positifs pour
d'autres de cette de cette réforme donc
c'est un peu normal que vous soyez que
vous soyez perdu parce que chacun donne
une orientation finalement à cette une
réforme des retraites
donnez-moi selon vous votre avis quelle
est la bonne réforme est-ce que celle-ci
est bonne
alors est-ce que celle-ci est bonne en
tout cas je sais pas moi de vous dire si
celle-ci est bonne elle est présentée
comme la réforme étant la réforme
équilibrée et là je comprends les
éléments de langage de notre
gouvernement parce que elle recule de
deux ans là je les garde de départ à la
retraite à la retraite pardon ça j'ai
compris on a tous compris ils sont tous
là dans la rue précisément pour cette
question là
on passe de 62 à 64 exactement
on ajoute
la durée de cotisation alors c'est là où
on commence un peu à perdre les gens
pour avoir une retraite à taux plein
optimum il faudra avoir travaillé 43 ans
d'accord donc en fait on n'est pas
assuré de partir à 64 ans j'ai cotisé
que 41 ans il faut que je fabrique il
faut vous faire les deux ans de plus et
je vous conseille pour ça le simulateur
la question le site du Figaro oui
64 ans
et d'autres de nos de nos
téléspectateurs spectateurs pardon le
découvriront aussi voilà ça c'est
l'histoire de la durée de cotisation il
faut avoir 43 ans
aujourd'hui l'âge de départ légal est à
62 ans mais il faut alors il faut aussi
un nombre de
la motivation c'est la réforme Touraine
que cette réforme d'Emmanuel Macron
accélère c'est-à-dire que plus
rapidement que prévu il faut qu'on
arrive assez assez 43 ans de cotisation
donc ça c'est le cadrage un peu
global des damnés de travail après il y
a toute cette partie qui est appelée
l'accompagnement socialiste c'est-à-dire
que les carrières longues sont
préservées voire améliorées par la
réforme on tient compte de tout un tas
de spécificités on va rentrer dans la
discussion et le débat sur la pénibilité
alors ça ça va être un gros morceau ça
ça va être les remettre encore dans la
rue voilà là je vous résume moi-même
très rapidement mais on a le cadrage
général de cette réforme est-ce que
cette réforme a une ambition sociale
sociétale où est-ce que c'est uniquement
pour que les comptes soient équilibre
dans 10 15 20 50
sur ces deux pieds alors financièrement
on a bien compris tout ce collectivement
même si certains le réfutent et qu'il y
aura toujours des débats là-dessus que
financièrement on
[Musique]
d'une simplicité évidente on vit que
longtemps on doit travailler plus
longtemps le gouvernement et on a plus
de baby-boomer qui sont en train
d'arriver à la retraite
mais pourquoi les Français ne le
comprennent pas c'est trop con c'est que
il y a un blocage l'équation financière
en tout cas et on peut débattre de
qu'est-ce qu'on veut laisser comme
situation à nos enfants est-ce que on
veut continuer cette retraite de
solidarité entre les générations mais
mais le fait que l'équation il y a les
baby-boomers on vit plus âgé il y a
davantage de personnes à la retraite
également c'est ce qu'on appelle le
ratio d'actifs par rapport aux retraités
tout ça n'est pas à la faveur de
l'équation financière donc BIM on se
dirige tout droit vers des déficits
cumulés qui sont abyssaux aujourd'hui ça
va cette année
à gauche et le rassemblement national
pour l'instant ça va il y a pas de
problème effectivement
c'est dommage ça ne va plus et oui c'est
demain que ça ne va plus et ça c'est
toujours compliqué à faire à faire
entendre c'est ce que Emmanuel Macron
vient de d'appeler la à l'instant la
responsabilité qui est en Espagne
exactement
et on lui a posé la question exactement
de le faire et c'est notre
responsabilité de le faire voilà c'est
l'équation elle est assez imparable en
tout cas financièrement parlant
lui il est sur place il est auprès des
manifestants Vincent en espérant que ça
passe cette fois que ça me coupe pas il
y a beaucoup de monde dans la rue et le
réseau est parfois difficile Vincent les
manifestants ils parlent de quoi
précisément cet âge de départ c'est ça
qu'il met en avant c'est ça qui est le
plus compréhensible pour tous
pour financer nos retraites c'est bien
évidemment oui effectivement ces étages
de départ qui posent problème beaucoup
nous ont dit moi le problème c'est que
voilà au lieu de partir sans deux ans je
vais partir à 64 ans on l'a beaucoup
entendu c'est sur ça surtout que les
manifestants veulent faire reculer le
gouvernement deux ans de plus c'est ce
qu'ils ne veulent pas c'est les slogans
majoritaires sont pour ce voilà pour ce
comment dire cette mesure
merci Vincent évidemment et puis si vous
avez si vous êtes un peu à l'écart si
vous arrivez à trouver des manifestants
vous leur posez la question
alors je vous ai trouvé je vous ai allez
vous trouver mieux que mieux qu'un
manifestant ne qu'un manifestant je vais
être rejoint par un député figurez-vous
qui est qui fait son écharpe pour venir
me rejoindre pour tout vous dire
exactement
bonjour Est-ce que vous déjà vous pouvez
vous présenter alors Bertrand Penchard
je suis le président du groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoires à
l'Assemblée nationale et députés de la
Meuse tout à l'heure que c'était votre
première manifestation contre oui
absolument moi je suis un parlementaire
de centre droit j'ai pas l'habitude
d'aller à des manifestations organisées
par des grands organisations syndicales
mais cette fois-ci avec d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des parlementaires de mon
groupe nous opposons fermement à cette
très mauvaise très mauvais projet de
décision d'augmentation aussi forte de
la durée de départ à la retraite
et c'est deux ans en plus qui pose
problème oui j'ai deux ans c'est deux
ans rien de justifier une réforme aussi
abrupte rien de soucis c'est
incompréhensible pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens je demande vraiment
solennellement au gouvernement de
revenir en arrière et puis de se
remettre la table de la discussion nous
avons beaucoup de propositions à quoi
sert d'allonger l'âge de durée à la
retraite si on règle pas par exemple
l'emploi des seniors tout ça est
incompréhensible c'est une réforme qui
est pas comprise par un très grand
nombre de nos concitoyens parce que
Emmanuel Macron le disait encore il y a
quelques années ça ne sert à rien de
repousser l'âge de la retraite parce que
les seniors sont pas assez embrouillés
en France
c'était exactement la formule du
président Macron il y a 5 ans qu'est-ce
qui a changé rien n'a changé le comité
le corps le dit comme on le dit très
très bien il y a certes à terme une
question de rééquilibrage le mode de
notre régime de retraite n'est pas comme
ça pas de façon aussi forte c'est c'est
vraiment pas compris par l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens vous du coup vous
attendez un retrait plus récent au moins
un abonnement tout va dépendre des
rapport de l'importance des
manifestations moi je pense que si une
très grande partie des Français
s'opposent massivement à ce projet de
réforme il faudra que le gouvernement
Vienne en arrière je l'avais d'ailleurs
dit à la première ministre qui tu sais
tu ferais mieux de t'attaquer une
réforme plus compréhensible plus
acceptée moins ambitieuse mais qui se
passe pas contre l'ensemble de
concitoyens une dernière question
aujourd'hui bah écoutez moi je suis la
première fois je peux pas vous dire je
sais que ça bouge pas tant que j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a beaucoup de monde
mais vos commentaires vous le diront
sans doute ce soir nous le fait très
bien merci beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
relativo je vous rappelle que je me
retrouve actuellement place de la
République un peu à l'écart de la place
de la République vu que pour l'instant
le cortège n'a pas avancé sur son axe
principal qui doit rejoindre Bastille
mais comme vous l'avez Timothée il
semblerait qu'il y a un autre cortège
soit parti par le boulevard Voltaire qui
pourrait rejoindre directement la place
de la Nation
en haut à droite et on le rejoindra dans
un instant on arrive ISO témoignage
étonnante Bertrand penchaquier est un
ancien l'UMP un ancien de l'UDI donc on
peut pas le taxer d'un fameux gauchiste
et lui il nous dit que cette réforme
elle est pas forcément très bonne oui
alors il dit plusieurs choses
intéressantes
ce député
oui alors effectivement il dit elle est
pas bonne il argumente pas beaucoup sur
le elle est pas très bonne
il dit aussi autre chose
non mais il dit par contre il dit un
truc qui est très intéressant il dit le
vrai sujet et d'ailleurs il commence son
intervention Barça et dit le vrai sujet
c'est l'emploi des seniors et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est connexe à
cette réforme des retraites et au sujet
de la manifestation aujourd'hui mais
tant que les seniors en France ne
resteront pas plus longtemps en
entreprise les efforts qui seront fait
et qui seront liés à cette réforme ne
porteront pas pleinement leurs fruits
c'est à dire que on repousse mais on
repousse mais si les gens ne
ne sont pas gardés par les entreprises
il faut être élucides là-dessus c'est
que c'est culturels du gouvernement oui
mais ils vont de fait les garder deux
ans de plus oui mais ils finiront
paraître soit licenciés soit placardiser
ou comme effet boomerang de reculer
l'âge de l'âge de départ de deux ans et
ça c'est une c'est une discussion de
négociation qui va s'ouvrir avec les
partenaires sociaux c'est c'est tout
l'enjeu en fait
des prochains mois à l'issue de cette
réforme j'ai une autre question vous
avez l'impression que vous allez me
répondre qu'à moi parce que j'ai besoin
de savoir mais je pense que beaucoup
d'internautes sont dans la même
situation que moi ils comprennent pas
forcément j'ai compris que c'est une
réforme paramétrique on touche un
paramètre en l'occurrence là de départ à
la retraite on doit être cotisations
le montant des pensions on n'y touche
pas ça c'est non et le taux de
cotisation ne touche pas non plus
pourquoi
parce que certains le réclament alors
certains effectivement
François Bayou ça a été évoqué aussi par
François Hollande disent il y avait
peut-être d'autres voix que celle du
recul de l'âge de la retraite il y avait
alors l'argument je vais vous donner
directement la réponse et puis après je
vais vous argumenter le truc
le gouvernement il dit c'est la moins
mauvaise des trois
scénarios qui se présentaient à nous des
solutions montant des pensions ça c'est
vite écart non mais montant des pensions
vous imaginez aujourd'hui baissez le
montant des de la retraite des gens
qu'on sort d'une année où on a que parlé
du pouvoir
d'achats de France les retraités
français étaient les mieux lotis
d'Europe et que finalement ils étaient
plus riches que les actifs mais ce sont
ceux dont le pouvoir d'achat recule le
plus vite d'accord c'est à dire que leur
niveau de vie c'est vrai aujourd'hui et
relativement plus élevé mais leur
pouvoir d'achat recule plus vite que
celui des autres d'accord donc si vous
voyez la pente non mais j'ai compris
quand vous venez de me donner un
argument moi j'aime bien quand vous me
faites comprendre comme ça clairement
les choses et donc ça c'est un premier
point donc évidemment on sort
de cette période d'ultra-inflation qui
est pas terminé politiquement
politiquement pour tout un tas de
raisons c'est impossible de baisser les
retraites des gens d'accord on a la
raison économique on a la raison
politique on ne baisse pas la retraite
des gens
ça se serait ça ne serait pas passé dans
l'opinion et l'autre l'autre
scénario c'était celui d'augmenter les
cotisations oui qui sont déjà très très
élevés en France là c'est à dire que le
salaire net baisse un peu mais ce que
les Français cotisent ou ce que les
patrons payent en plus
donc les patrons déjà un bon paquet de
charges sociales
si on prend les comparaisons au CPE les
courbes là à la France on est on est
bien au top c'est 28% les cotisations en
moyenne aujourd'hui en France donc
est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire que
on
abîme la compétitivité des entreprises
parce qu'elle paye davantage on abime
Macron
de précisément la politique économique
qu'il mène depuis
son premier quinquennat et même avant
quand il travaillait avec François
Hollande donc on brille de la
compétitivité des entreprises on joue
sur le pouvoir d'achat des salariés bien
sûr dans toute cette période aussi où on
essaye de redonner et redorer la valeur
travail se dire qu'on prend sur la
cotisations
sur le salarié ça va et au final en bout
de chaîne celui qui paye c'est l'emploi
donc c'est le français
donc je vous schématise vraiment le
processus économique mais augmenter les
cotisations c'est gagnant pour personne
on affaiblit les possibilités d'embauche
c'est ce que vous dites alors que
Emmanuel Macron le dit depuis maintenant
[Musique]
un million de personnes dans la rue
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas c'est celle
qu'il a trouvé la plus judicieuse alors
on va et qui nous remet à la moyenne de
tout à fait à la moyenne de nos
partenaires
Timothée vous êtes avec une manifestante
tiens dites-moi qu'est-ce qu'elle vous
dit qu'est-ce qu'il a mis en colère
qu'est-ce qu'il a pousse à être dans la
rue aujourd'hui
oui Thibault avec Sabrina qui est venu
dans la rue aujourd'hui pour manifester
contre cette réforme des retraites pour
quelles raisons êtes-vous venu
manifester pourquoi c'était important
pour vous d'être là aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui vous met en colère ce qui
me met en colère mais justement je fais
partie de la tranche qui va devoir
travailler 2 ans supplémentaires
aujourd'hui
j'arrive à mes 60 ans et donc
ça devient compliqué je suis gardienne
d'immeubles et dans ma profession en
fait travailler jusqu'à 64 ans ça
devient de plus en plus dur déjà à 60
ans on est déjà épuisé par la pénibilité
Marie visée au disait à l'instant en
plateau que finalement Emmanuel Macron
il avait plusieurs options sur la table
il a choisi peut-être pour lui la moins
pire qu'est-ce que vous en pensez par
rapport à cette à cette réforme mais ce
que je suis est-ce que Emmanuel Macron
est-ce qu'il avait quelque part est-ce
qu'il avait le choix
il avait le choix
alors qu'est-ce qu'il aurait pu faire
d'autre peut-être faire travailler
peut-être davantage de seniors plutôt
que de les mettre en pré-retraite ou au
chômage et donner aussi l'occasion à des
jeunes de pouvoir travailler plus tôt
c'est-à-dire que leur donner du travail
et donc ça aurait pu donc donner un
petit peu de au potentiel de retraite
des futurs retraités ça fait très
longtemps qu'une telle intercédicale
n'avait pas été formée de nombreux
syndicats qui sont présents aujourd'hui
c'est important pour vous qu'est-ce qui
se dit dans dans les rangs des syndicats
vous faites partie de l'USA comme vous
me comme vous me le disiez qu'est-ce qui
se dit dans les rangs des syndicats et
en particulier de l'une ça nous sommes
ravis qu'aujourd'hui enfin les syndicats
ne passent pas pour les méchants de
services et que on puisse se rassembler
autant de monde pour quelque chose qui
concerne toute la population en fait
vous êtes venus également avec avec une
banderole alors que le cortège comme
vous le pouvez le voir Thibault reprend
il y avait eu un petit moment un petit
moment d'attente il faut dire qu'il y a
énormément de monde ici le cortège qui
continue de de reprendre vers cette
place de la Bastille une dernière
question peut-être avec vous Sabrina
vous êtes venu avec avec cette j'allais
dire cette banderole en tous les cas
cette pancarte qu'est-ce que cela
représente bah ça représente la
population aujourd'hui qui
il y a de plus en plus de personnes qui
partent à leur truc qui devrait partir à
la retraite et aujourd'hui ce que nous
demandons c'est de pouvoir partir en
bonne santé et de ne pas partir cassé on
va peut-être lire ce que vous avez écrit
et puis montrer sur cette image de
Julien Leclerc cette pancarte voilà
ras-le-bol de pédaler la retraite avant
l'arthrite voilà pour cette pour cette
banderole avec donc cette manifestante
qui continue et bien comme l'ensemble du
cortège de se diriger vers cette place
de la Bastille alors que nous avons
certaines informations qui nous viennent
de journalistes du Figaro qui sont
présents au niveau de la place de la
Bastille qui me disent qu'il a eu
quelques affrontements quelques charges
sur la place de la Bastille ici en tous
les cas Bouver la Voltaire boulevard
Voltaire pardon je peux vous dire que
pas d'affrontement l'ambiance est plutôt
plutôt calme et tout se déroule dans
l'ordre ici sur ce boulevard Voltaire
ISO rédactrice en chef au service
économique du Figaro on parlait donc de
ces points qu'on pouvait toucher dans
une réforme paramétrique pourquoi
Emmanuel Macron abandonné cette idée de
cette grande réforme systémique avec la
fin des régimes spéciaux sur le modèle
suédois qui aurait réglé tous les
problèmes définitivement pourquoi ça
s'est passé à l'as passé à l'AS il y
avait déjà enfin elle avait déjà
provoqué des vies de réactions entre
elles sa réforme systémique
il avait longtemps dans depuis longtemps
dans sa tête décidé de l'abandonner
justement parce qu'il pense que ce
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui présente
aujourd'hui est plus acceptable que la
réforme systémique dont il rêvait au
début de son premier quinquennat et puis
aujourd'hui nous l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure on dit et aussi il dit vous
m'avez élu sur sur ce que je vous
présente aujourd'hui j'ai la légitimité
de de faire ce que je vous présente
aujourd'hui puisque c'est le projet du
gouvernement donc oui il est il est
passé à autre chose Emmanuel Macron il a
laissé derrière lui cette réforme dont
il réveille
comme premier ministre qui lui poussait
largement
[Musique]
ça nous aujourd'hui face à un front
syndical uni c'est rare ça faisait très
longtemps ça faisait très très longtemps
parce que c'est risqué pour des
syndicats de se mettre en déjà ils sont
pas complètement tout sur la sur la même
ligne on sait les réformistes les moins
réformistes et par exemple du tout
et puis ils sont parfois concurrents
dans les élections évidemment voilà bien
sûr c'est évidemment un élément de
considération et puis et puis c'est
risqué pour eux de se mettre tous
ensemble
si ça marche pas si ça marche pas si
bien que prévu
ils aiment bien un peu ce singulariser
les uns des autres bah là enfin c'est de
constater qu'ils ont ils ont fait le bon
choix
compte tenu de leur position commune
face à la réforme des retraites il y
avait une certaine logique ce qui soit
tous ensemble aujourd'hui
puisque pendant 20 ans on s'est demandé
si la CFDT allait tenir sur sa ligne
dure contre le relèvement de l'âge de la
retraite elle a tenu donc ils sont tous
ils sont tous ensemble aujourd'hui sont
en train de préparer les tables d'après
ils sont en train de saura ce soir de
discuter de la prochaine journée de
mobilisation des prochaines journées de
mobilisation il va y en avoir plusieurs
notre ami Laurent Berger parce que lui
il peut être un des
maillons qui peut faire changer les
choses et qui peut faire entrer la
protestation dans une autre dimension ou
au contraire l'affaiblir la CFDT dans la
rue cette fois pourquoi précisément
alors qu'on le rappelle il y a 3 ans 2
ans et demi il était clairement dans le
camp d'Emmanuel Macron il poussait à ce
que ça
de la réforme systémique il a toujours
mis une ligne rouge Laurent Berger à la
hausse de l'âge de la retraite donc il
tient sa ligne oui mais alors il y a 2
ans et demi il y avait quand même une
hausse de l'âge de départ
n'était qu'un élément d'une réforme plus
large
et pour lui alors il est disait pas
comme ça mais pour lui ça passait
cet ensemble qui était bien plus
ambitieux cette retraite à point voilà
ça va se passer ça aujourd'hui ça ne
passe pas est-ce que vous pensez que la
rue peut faire fléchir le gouvernement
historiquement lorsqu'on remonte dans le
temps parce que un million de personnes
dans la rue bon d'accord très bien et
puis après est-ce que le gouvernement
peut se dire ah il y a une du recul
alors
c'est pas son état d'esprit finalement
mais ça Nicole début
pour en avoir discuté avec des ministres
du gouvernement ce qui nous ce qui nous
ont expliqué c'est que ils avaient deux
possibilités dans leur stratégie de face
à cette réforme des retraites soit ils
présentaient un texte
qui allait trop loin dans leur esprit et
ça leur permet de négocier et de faire
du marchandage avec les syndicats
pendant la discussion parlementaires qui
va commencer bientôt soit il mettait
directement sur la table un texte qui
les estimait équilibré ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui avec du coup comme condition
de ne rien lâcher
ils se disent oui on n'a pas choisi le
moyen le plus facile on met aujourd'hui
le texte qui nous semble être le bon
mais ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
tienne sur ce texte et ça c'est l'état
d'esprit d'Emmanuel Macron si je parle
chiffre à partir de combien de personnes
dans la rue et syndicats
revendiqueront une victoire bon il
revendiqueront une victoire quoi qu'il
arrive
on sait pas s'ils avaient vraiment une
inquiétude mais mais le fait de ce
million qui semble être dépassé on a
passé le cap du mur pour eux c'est déjà
énorme donc pour eux dans le discours
dans les éléments de langage dans ce
qu'ils vont aller raconter dans les
cortèges et à la télé ce soir ils auront
gagné ça c'est sûr nous verrons ce que
nous disent les syndicarniens dans un
instant retrouve à Timothée de l'aime
qu'est-ce qui est le plus marquant la
rue j'ai entendu qu'est-ce qui peut qui
a même plus à même de faire
transiger le gouvernement est-ce que
c'est la rue ou est-ce que c'est les
blocages je pense aux profs je pense
auraffinerie au transport évidemment
c'est une bonne question c'est
évidemment un combiné des deux qui
comptent
une réponse
évidemment que les les trains sur une
journée la question ça va être à ce que
ça ça va durer si les transports sont
bloqués dans la durée
si les gens ne peuvent pas aller
travailler parce que n'oublions pas que
toute la France ne peut pas
télétravailler le prisme très parisien
il faut s'en méfier
mais même pas j'ai lu ça car des
Français
allez entre un quart et un tiers mais
voilà j'ai entendu si vous me dites
qu'il est trop je vous crois et
[Musique]
donc pensons à tous les autres bloquer
une journée ça va bloquer sur la
longueur et c'est un peu ça qui
déterminera
qui déterminera
la suite des réflexions de l'exécutif
face à cette France à l'arrêt ou pas
quand on se rapproche de la du monde et
d'ailleurs si le cortège n'avance pas
c'est parce qu'il y a beaucoup de monde
dernière question Marie quelles sont les
secteurs les plus mobilisés là ce matin
et quels sont ceux qui ne sont pas
encore totalement mobilisés et qui
pourraient faire
donner une dynamique plus positive enfin
plus impressionnante encore en mouvement
alors ceux qui devait se mobiliser ils
sont mobiliser aujourd'hui ils y
arriveront pas en cours de route
on a vu là on regarde depuis ce matin
donc il y a des jeunes il y a beaucoup
de jeunes il y a des lycéens il y a des
retraités non concernés par la réforme
qui viennent soutenir les générations
futures
il y a la fonction publique qui est
assez mobilisée on est presque à 30% de
de grévistes dans la fonction publique
on est un peu plus de 40% chez les
gaziers de mémoire
donc ça c'était c'était les les gros les
gros morceaux avec évidemment SNCF et
RATP
[Musique]
est-ce que les étudiants peuvent venir
donner de l'ampleur au mouvement mais 68
évidemment on en est très loin je fais
pas de comparaison hâtives mais
forcément ça donne une impulsion oui
alors on peut peut-être juste venir à 95
ou il y avait eu
entre 1 et 2 millions de manifestants
dès la première journée alors chiffre
syndicat ou chiffre
police
c'est un petit peu difficile
tout comme il était difficile il y a 48
heures où il y a 72 heures de savoir ce
que donnerait cette mobilisation savoir
comment elle va tenir dans la durée je
trouve ça assez difficile aussi de le
prédire donc moi je je m'arrange pas la
semaine prochaine avec plaisir parfait
merci beaucoup Marie Viso rédactrice en
chef au service économique du Figaro
Timothée de l'aime vous êtes avec une
une députée c'est ça vous avez la parole
[Musique]
absolument antibois avec Sabrina et BAE
député Europe écologie des
Hauts-de-Seine bonjour madame la députée
pourquoi est-ce que c'était important
pour vous d'être là aujourd'hui à cette
manifestation bah en fait c'était très
important d'être présente aujourd'hui
sur cette mobilisation historique
puisqu'on voit bien qu'on a affaire une
réforme totalement injuste le
gouvernement depuis plusieurs semaines à
coup de mensonges éontés nous explique
que cette réforme est nécessaire or on
voit bien qu'on a plus de 70% de la
population française qui est opposée à
cette réforme dans toutes les catégories
sociales d'ailleurs quel que soit les
professions et puis surtout dans les
différents rapports du corps dont le
gouvernement se sert d'arguments à coups
d'arguments il n'y a qu'un seul scénario
le plus défavorable qui indique que
potentiellement on aurait un
déséquilibre à hauteur de 12 milliards
mais que ces deux équilibres reviendrait
de lui-même finalement à un équilibre
donc aucune raison de faire cette
réforme totalement injuste 50 à 80 000
personnes étaient attendues ici pour
cette manifestation aujourd'hui un
chiffre évidemment difficile à vérifier
en tous les cas dans notre position
parce qu'on a du mal à après l'ampleur
de cette mobilisation tous les cas ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de monde est-ce que cette
mobilisation c'est une réussite selon
vous alors c'est une mobilisation qui
est une grande réussite parce que c'est
le premier rendez-vous c'est le début de
cette mobilisation contre cette réforme
quand je me dis comme je le disais que
totalement injuste et on voit bien que
finalement tous les corps ont répondu
présent nous sommes très nombreux on est
tellement nombreux que vous voyez ça
fait plusieurs heures qu'on a démarré il
y a un corps des gens qui partent de la
République donc oui c'est un rendez-vous
réussi et ce n'est que le premier
quelques retours nous viennent de ce qui
se passe sur la place de la Bastille
quelques affrontements quelques
débordements c'est dommage ça gâche le
message c'est toujours dommage quand une
manifestation se termine mal ce que
j'espère c'est que le débordements
seront vraiment à la marge et que ce
qu'on retiendra de cette journée c'est
cette mobilisation historique contre ce
projet de réforme un mot Sabrina sebahi
sur le fond de cette réforme Emmanuel
Macron a consulté les syndicats les
oppositions également il y a un certain
nombre de mesures renseignement dans
cette réforme ça n'est pas suffisant
selon vous non ce n'est absolument pas
suffisant parce que cette réforme elle
ne devrait pas avoir lieu donc on n'a
pas besoin d'avoir des mesures de
compensation pour une réforme qui est
totalement inutile si vous voulez si
demain on nous expliquait que le système
de retraite serait totalement
déséquilibré qui aurait un risque qu'il
n'y ait plus de caisse de retraite pour
les gens on pourrait un petit peu ce qui
est manuel Macron dit en tous les coups
oui mais sauf qu'il se base sur des
scénarios dont en fait un seul scénario
prévoit ce déséquilibre et pendant
quelques années de manière transitoire
donc en réalité cette réforme est
totalement inutile nous n'avons pas
besoin et au contraire nous ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut préserver
les travailleurs et notamment les
travailleurs les plus précaires qui vont
être les plus impactés par cette réforme
parce que ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler très tôt ce sont eux qui vont
devoir travailler le plus longtemps dans
des conditions déplorables et on le sait
aujourd'hui la moyenne d'âge en bonne
santé en fait elle a diminué et pour les
hommes à 62 ans souvent c'est déjà la
mort donc qu'est-ce qu'on attend en fait
de cette catégorie finalement de
personnes les plus précaires qui
travaille jusqu'à la mort c'est ça en
fait le projet d'Emmanuel Macron et nous
on nous disons que ce n'est pas de
l'autre aujourd'hui c'est la première
grande mobilisation contre cette réforme
des retraites et qu'est-ce qu'il va
suivre après on sait que le texte doit
arriver à l'Assemblée nationale au début
du mois de février est-ce que vous
appelez à ce qu'il y ait d'autres
mobilisations d'autres manifestations
d'ici là oui bien sûr alors il y aura
d'autres mobilisations ça c'est évident
on se mobilisera dans la rue mais aussi
à l'Assemblée nationale parce que vous
voyez bien ce texte que ce soit sur le
fond ou sur la forme le choix de le
faire passer par un projet rectificatif
de la loi de financement de sécurité
sociale c'est aussi un déni démocratique
pour les parlementaires qui ont été élus
par le peuple donc nous ce qu'on nous
disons c'est que nous resterons
mobiliser bien sûr pour les prochains
rendez-vous et il y en aura d'autres car
vous le voyez la mobilisation est
réussie et les gens ne lâcheront pas sur
cette réforme et aussi à l'hémicycle les
parlementaires nous sommes prêts aussi à
nous battre jusqu'au bout quel va être
la stratégie des députés de votre groupe
écologie Europe Écologie Les Verts à
l'Assemblée nationale qu'allez-vous
faire pour essayer et bien convaincre le
gouvernement peut-être et bien de
modifier cette réforme et bien nous
déposerons des amendements pour
rectifier au maximum ce texte jusqu'à ce
qu'on au final notre espoir c'est que
par la rue et par nos amendements on
fasse plier le gouvernement sur cette
réforme j'espère que le texte soit
retiré absolument c'est l'objectif voilà
pour cette réaction de Sabrina Sebaï
député Europe Écologie Les Verts des
Hauts-de-Seine Thibault alors que le
cortège continue de se diriger vers
cette vers cette place de la Bastille et
ici et bien vous le voyez ces drapeaux
de la CFDT vous le voyez sur ces images
de Julien Leclerc la CFDT qui qui
continue et bien de marcher lentement
mais sûrement vers cette place de la
Bastille un petit moteur
mais vous voyez Vincent roseron en bas à
droite de l'image Vincent vous êtes vous
aussi à proximité de la place de la
Bastille racontez-moi ce que vous voyez
j'entends dire qu'il y aurait quelques
échauffourés est-ce que c'est le cas
est-ce que vous voyez ça autour de vous
bonne journée
alors
[Musique]
alors j'ai passé très bien entendu votre
question parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
nouveaux autour de moi ce qui est en
train de se passer c'est que je vais
vous montrer ce qui se passe c'est qu'en
fait ici c'est le le chemin normal de la
manifestation qui est bloqué en fait
depuis deux heures et que veut emprunter
la CGT mais le il est toujours bloqué et
du coup ce qui se passe depuis c'est que
d'autres syndicats passent par un autre
chemin par le pouvoir Voltaire sur
lequel est Timothée d'Hélène vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure et là vous voyez
c'est une ça qui était bloqué sur la
place de la République depuis le début
de la manifestation et qu'il a passe par
cet endroit donc voilà la place qui
commence à se vider en fait petit à
petit finalement mais en passant par un
endroit à notre itinéraire on va dire
allez intéressant ça
il y a trop de monde peut-être dans
cette cette manifestation et donc que
certaines véhicules soit obligé de
passer par d'autres endroits c'est pas
forcément autorisé enfin si sans doute
que la préfecture a dû donner son
autorisation je vois du gaz autour de
vous Vincent est-ce que sont des gaz à
lacrymogènes ou non seulement des
fumigènes
non non ce ne sont que des fumes ce sont
que des fumigènes et de la fumée des
merguez aussi un peu mais beaucoup de
beaucoup de fumigènes là qui ont été
craqué à l'instant
mais voilà il dort beaucoup de films
l'ambiance est très bonne enfant ici
place de la République vraiment on n'a
pas vu qu'on a vu aucun débordement en
tout cas ici place de la République
merci Vincent allez on vous laisse
avancer et vous voyez que Sophie Ravinel
me rejoint grand reporter au service
politique du Figaro en charge de la
gauche vous revenez de la manifestation
bon comment ça s'est passé ce début là
avec les leaders politiques les leaders
syndicaux c'est pas tous les jours qu'on
va ça
alors qu'on joue beaucoup plus un tout
petit instant Sophia en train de voir
les premières images d'affrontements
malheureusement pour l'instant ça a
l'air marginal voilà mais quand même on
est obligé de les commenter et vous
signaler si vous ne revenez que c'est la
première fois il est 16h39 que nous
voyons des images comme celle-ci depuis
le début de cette manifestation je vous
laisse reprendre Sophie comment ça s'est
passé ça s'est passé on a vu arriver
marine tondeuillier sur la place de la
République en première donc c'est la
nouvelle responsable du parti des
écologistes élevés qui a été rejoint
très rapidement par Fabien Roussel du
Nord lui aussi le patron des communistes
rejoint ensuite par Olivier Faure et
tous les trois sont patrons des
socialistes sortant les socialistes et
qui ont rejoint les insoumis Mathilde
panneaux à lexicorbières toute la bande
des députés insoumis ils se sont tous
retrouvés pour essayer parlementaire de
rejoindre la tête des responsables
syndicaux il était à peu près 13h30
quand ils ont tenté ils ont pris une rue
parallèle pour rejoindre le cortège les
responsables syndicaux n'ont pas
vraiment voulu deux alors ça m'intéresse
parce que Vincent roseron qui était sur
place tout à l'heure on nous a dit qu'il
a vu arriver Olivier fort qui n'arrivait
pas vraiment à entrer dans la dans la
manif et en fait vous dites que c'est
les leaders syndicaux qui voulaient pas
faire la photo avec quoi c'était un peu
compliqué c'est-à-dire que Pierre
Lepeletier était présent sur place avec
moi mon frère qui suit la gauche notre
binôme de choc et il a pu observer avec
moi cette difficulté qu'ont eu c'est
socialiste c'est communiste ses
écologistes ces insoumis à aller saluer
comme il le souhaitait les 8
responsables syndicaux qui donc était
dans le cortège de tête et ils ont été
ballottés ces politiques d'un côté de
l'autre dans une foule absolument
étouffante et au bout d'un moment mais
ils ont abandonné et il n'y a pas
vraiment eu ou peut-être de façon
anecdotique en tout cas pas de façon
médiatique en tout cas pas que nous
ayons pu l'observer peut-être voilà mais
on a les images
[Musique]
et moi je vois là les pompiers qui sont
effectivement les pompiers en grève il y
en avait pas mal que j'ai croisé sur le
cortège
de fait donc c'était un front uni de
politique aujourd'hui à côté d'un front
uni de syndicats et les deux ne marchent
pas de conseils
alors ça arrive ou pas ou c'est on l'a
dit 12 ans qu'il n'y avait pas eu un
front syndical uni et avec les
politiques c'est déjà arrivé par le
passé il faut remonter à combien de
temps pour avoir tant que ça c'était je
pense 2019 la dernière
réforme volonté de réforme des retraites
l'idée d'Édouard Philippe non mais il y
avait un front uni de politique d'accord
voilà est-ce que vous avez fait la photo
avec ce qu'on avait vu la photo
Mélenchon Martinez
alors ici Mélenchon Martinez oui c'était
un petit peu avant des tensions il y
avait des rassemblements là je ne me
rappelle plus exactement s'il y avait
Mélenchon Martinez aujourd'hui c'est sûr
qu'il y a une faille de ce côté-là et
des très forte entre disons la direction
sortante de la CGT et le patron des
insoumis Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui avait
posé sa date avec les jeunes du 21
janvier donc samedi qui vient les
syndicats la CGT en tête très vexée
d'avoir été
pris de cours par les politiques opposés
leurs propres dates avant donc le 19
prévu à l'origine de se retrouver un peu
plus tard bref un peu des gros
des tensions qui se lisent aujourd'hui
dans
une sorte d'union puisqu'il est de fait
ils sont tous contre la Réunion
union sur les idées absolument mais
alors on veut pas faire de photos
ensemble enfin ou certains essaient
pas quelque chose d'original il y a une
très forte pudeur chez les syndicats
dans leur rapport aux politiques c'est
toute l'histoire de la France c'est
toute l'histoire des relations entre les
politiques et les syndicats et
évidemment à l'origine un petit peu la
domination du Parti communiste sur la
CGT aujourd'hui il y a des liens
historiques et évidemment des tensions
entre les communistes et les insoumis et
tout ça est un peu compliqué peut-être
pour nos auditeurs ce qui faut retenir
je pense c'est que il y a un front
unique syndicat un franc unique
politique et une unité à peu près
une volonté commune à tous de s'opposer
au projet du gouvernement il y a une
contre-réforme qui est en cours et qui
va être proposé par les politiques au
Parlement notamment et je crois qu'en
tout cas le côté massif de cette
mobilisation
n'échappe à personne et certes s'il y a
des tensions au sein de chacun des
groupes parce qu'il y en a évidemment
aussi au sein de la CGT il y en a
évidemment aussi entre la CFDT et la
démocratie et heureusement
on revient évidemment sur
ces manifestations les ambitions
politiques de chacun le jeu politique de
chacun mais d'abord on retrouve Timothée
Delam Timothée vous êtes avec des
pompiers vous les avez vu Sophie
Timothée vous avez la parole vous avez
la main on va te retrouver
oui avec les pompiers vous le voyez sur
ces images de Julien Leclerc je suis
avec l'un d'eux sapeur-pompiers dites
nous d'abord quel est votre poste
précisément et pourquoi vous êtes là
aujourd'hui donc je suis Jérémy Courtel
je suis donc secrétaire général adjoint
à la Fédération autonome SPPP pâtes donc
Syndicat national des pompiers aux
présentatifs
pourquoi c'était important pour vous de
venir manifester aujourd'hui alors
c'était important pour nous pourquoi
parce que déjà c'est en soutient la
population française qui se verra donc
du coup impacter donc de deux ans
supplémentaires avant de pouvoir avoir
le droit de partir à la retraite notre
profession sera pas épargné par ce cette
réforme là aujourd'hui c'est 57 ans pour
pouvoir avoir le droit de partir à la
retraite demain avec la réforme ce sera
59 ans et pour nous c'est inacceptable
de pouvoir voir des collègues à cet âge
là partir en intervention au risque qui
peuvent prendre sur intervention vous
êtes très nombreux en tout cas on l'a vu
sur ces images me disiez vous une
ambiance plutôt plutôt bonne enfance
dans le cortège l'ambiance elle est
bonne elle est bonne parce que derrière
on veut se faire entendre on veut pas
entre guillemets qui est des clivages
qui permettent une quelconque
récupération qui permettrait du coup de
mettre à mal ce mouvement social et
qu'est-ce que vous dites à Emmanuel
Macron alors que le projet de loi doit
être présenté en Conseil des ministres
dans quelques jours il doit ensuite
arriver à l'Assemblée nationale
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous lui
dites aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
espérez que le projet de loi soit
purement et simplement retiré est-ce que
vous souhaitez qu'il soit nous ce qu'on
lui demande et ce qu'on souhaite
principalement c'est qu'il écoute et qui
voit ce qui est en train de se passer
les pompiers c'est une des professions
qui est au plus proche de la population
on va dans là-bas sa rencontre surtout
quand elle va mal donc on est bien
conscient de la détresse sociale qui
peut y avoir aujourd'hui dans le pays et
ne reculer la je retraite FRAC derrière
ça sera encore beaucoup plus compliqué
avec des travailleurs qui seront
beaucoup plus âgés qui avec tous les les
mots qui sont liés avec notre société
aujourd'hui
voilà Thibault pour cette réaction donc
des sapeurs-pompiers qui sont présents
pour cette mobilisation alors que le
cortège continue de se déployer vers la
place de la Bastille avec quelques
fumigène que je vois au loin des
fumigènes bleues également rouge et
quelques pétards également alors que
voilà le jour commence petit à petit à
tomber ici mais le cortège qui continue
d'avancer vers la place de la Bastille
le cortège qui avance difficilement
Sophie vous l'a dit tout à l'heure j'ai
du mal à se lancer c'est évidemment
parce que il y avait aussi les syndicats
qui disaient en bougera pas tant que les
politiques sont là et puis les
politiques qui voulaient quand même leur
image merci beaucoup bonne journée un
petit peu eu du mal à démarrer à cause
de ça
de fait ensuite bon il y a eu évidemment
tout tout toutes les les stationnements
successifs et vraiment vraiment beaucoup
de monde je discutais avec Clémentine
Autain tout à l'heure qui me disait
c'est un parfum de 1980 député de la
France insoumise de Seine-Saint-Denis un
tout petit peu considéré comme une voie
beaucoup la tondeuse au sein de
mouvement des insoumis mais ça c'est une
autre étape
disons qu'il y a quelques tensions mais
qui n'ont pas lieu d'être en ce moment
en tout cas c'est leur volonté d'essayer
de les masquer tant que la mobilisation
sociale est très forte et on voyait à la
je vois beaucoup d'instruments de
musique
et c'est vrai que cette mobilisation est
il faut comprendre aussi pourquoi elle
est si forte c'est à dire qu'il y a un
jeu qui se passe au Parlement
dire qu'il y a les 49-3 peut-être que
nos auditeurs maintenant commencent à
savoir ce que c'est voilà
le gouvernement qui peut passer en force
entre guillemets sans absolument avoir
des députés mais en mettant en jeu ça
des potentiels potentiel d’institution
absolument et il ne peut pas le faire
éternellement sauf dans quelques cas de
figure notamment sur les finances mais
il y a aussi le 47,1 et le 47 ans c'est
un peu cette façon
je vais pas revenir dessus mais c'est
une façon de limiter le débat dans le
temps en fait ça permet d'accélérer
absolument la procédure de débat et donc
ça contraint dans le temps et donc il
fallait pour les organisations
syndicales et politiques que la
mobilisation soit très forte parce que
du style absolument la force appelle la
force et donc une mobilisation de cette
nature peut inviter ceux qui étaient
hésitant à descendre dans un deuxième
temps soit samedi avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et ce sera peut-être d'autant
plus facile que ce n'est pas un jour de
semaine et donc on n'est pas obligé de
poser un jour et c'est vrai que une
mobilisation de cette nature dans un
contexte économique très compliqué
d'inflation où les Français notamment
les plus populaires ont vraiment du mal
à boucler la fin du mois c'est un
sacrifice de participer à une
mobilisation de cette nature et donc
évidemment
la foule dit quelque chose peut-être de
la colère François-Xavier nous expliquer
tout à l'heure que c'était un jeu de
calendrier finalement entre le
gouvernement qui essaye d'accélérer les
choses
les forces syndicales et les mouvements
de politique de position qui essayent de
mobiliser le plus possible avant les
vacances absolument aussi est assez fin
et c'est un jeu politique une petite
fenêtre voilà je réponds quand même à
certains de nos interlocuteurs est-ce
qu'il y a des violences alors pour tout
vous dire je lis ce que nous disent nos
journalistes sur le terrain alors va
interpellations à Paris en marche de la
manifestation selon la préfecture de
police donc va interpellations étaient
opérées lors de la manifestation alors
que dès lors ont éclaté entre les forces
de l'ordre et les manifestants autour de
la place de la Bastille les heures ce
sont déroulés alors que les délégations
syndicales se trouvaient loin derrière
on avait dit tout à l'heure que ça avait
du mal à se lancer parce que finalement
les heures qui ont pu avoir lieu
la place de la Bastille allez on revient
la politique Sophie je sais que c'est
vous suivez la gauche mais vous avez une
vision d'ensemble que faisait Emmanuel
en Espagne aujourd'hui
et bien écoutez qui sait s'il n'avait
alors il y a évidemment des enjeux des
enjeux internationaux des enjeux
européens moi ce que je peut-être qu'il
avait envie un petit peu de détourner le
regard de cette mobilisation c'est ce
que diront en tout cas évidemment les
les forces unies de la gauche
et on peut dire de la même chose de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'est-il allait
faire à Marseille puisqu'il n'était pas
à Paris aujourd'hui c'est son habitude
ça non non et oui quand il était député
de Marseille mais je vous rappelle qu'il
n'est plus député de Marseille et donc
on me répond du côté du Parti communiste
comme des insoumis oui mais Marseille et
la deuxième ville de France mais c'est
la capitale des luttes sociales c'est
comme ça qu'il perçoivent cette ville la
cité phocéenne j'arrive pas à saisir
votre parallèle entre manuel Macron loin
de la France et Mélenchon je vais vous
raconter c'est qu'en fait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon justement est un peu en
tension avec quelques-uns chez lui et
quelques-uns à la CGT et sans doute
pouvait-il redouter des tensions plus
fortes encore entre le cortège politique
et le cortège syndical si Jean-Luc
Mélenchon avait été présent et donc sans
doute a-t-il voulu tenter de d'apaiser
un petit peu
les les relations pour monter donc ce
front uni évidemment il était aussi
invité à Marseille et
bien écoutez Emmanuel Macron je ne sais
pas on ira pas dire comme les gilets
jaunes qu'il craignait de se faire
déloger à l'Élysée je crois que ce n'est
absolument pas le cas nous sommes loin
et nous sommes très très loin de ces
heures de décembre lorsque les gilets
jaunes il y a quelques années menacés
[Musique]
il y a 11 ministres avec lui dont Bruno
Le Maire dont Gérald Darmanin dominice
qui sont quand même concernés l'un par
la réforme des retraites mais c'est un
ministre du Travail mais Bruno Le Maire
l'autre part de potentiels et même sans
échauffouré une manifestation de cet
importance dans les rues de la capitale
elle dépend forcément du ministère de
l'Intérieur absolument et
c'est là ce je dirais en terme de
communication politique même si c'est
toujours compliqué parce qu'on peut lire
les choses différemment du selon
l'endroit où on se trouve mais en tout
cas vu de la gauche ça ne donne pas le
sentiment d'un président à l'écoute même
si comme vous l'avez très justement
souligné le calendrier international
n'est pas guidée par le calendrier
social et inversement mais c'est vrai
que ça donne bon on va voir comment tout
ça se termine j'ai du mal à croire que
ça peut se terminer très très calmement
parce que on a toujours eu la preuve
jusqu'ici quand même de fortes tensions
dans les dans les queues de cortège
je sais qu'il y a eu de la part de des
forces de l'ordre et Christophe Cornavin
est venu vous le dire je crois en début
d'après-midi beaucoup de de vérification
énormément de
d'un travail en amont effectué pour
éviter les tensions
évidemment il y a un travail de ce mois
et puis surtout les personnalités leader
de des mouvements
qui veulent casser l'ambiance est casser
les boutiques sont repérées sont
exfiltrés on essaye d'empêcher qui qui
qu'ils arrivent même sur place et
surtout avec le matériel mais nous on a
vu aussi dans le cortège beaucoup de de
jeunes beaucoup de lycéens
que dans certaines manifestations
évidemment mais il y en avait discuté
avec Daniel Simonet député LFI de la
donc débuter insoumise de Paris qui
était avec des lycéens ce matin qui les
a fait une très déterminés très
politisés bon il faut la croire mais de
fait
il y a des images je pense que cette
mobilisation cette fermeture d'école
aujourd'hui qu'on peut observer
dit quelque chose je parlais aussi avec
Julien Bayou l'ancien patron des
écologistes qui est qui se fait discret
mais qui était absolument là dans la
manifestation et très engagée avec les
autres même si je crois qu'il est assez
fatigué de tout ce qui a une courbe
polémique sur lui à titre sur son
personnel politique très personnel
et il me disait avoir discuté avec
Laurent Berger et Laurent Berger lui
ayant 10 à surprise ou disons le fait
qu'il est observé qu'il y avait beaucoup
de de salariés
modestes qui d'habitude ne prennent pas
part à ce type de manifestation et qui
était cette fois-ci engagée
pour lutter contre cette réforme
de la gauche de toutes ces
problématiques internes avec chacun qui
essaye de se faire voir sans braquer
avec les autres pendant un peu du
gouvernement
est-ce que ces images là peuvent le
faire vaciller ou pas encore et on voit
Vincent Rosemont en bas à droite de
l'image on ira le voir dans un instant
est-ce que ça peut ça peut avoir Macron
là depuis Barcelone et du monde quand
même là disons que ils ont la
possibilité de faire bouger un petit peu
le texte quand il va être discuté
débattu à l'Assemblée nationale et je je
discutais hier avec une ministre du
gouvernement qui me disait qu'il y avait
évidemment dans l'esprit de tous l'idée
que ce texte était là pour être discuté
pour être amendé alors jusqu'à quel
point évidemment là aussi on est dans la
communication politique on l'ignore mais
en tout cas et on ne sait pas bien sur
quoi il pourrait être prêt à à bouger
sans doute pas sur les fondamentaux de
cette réforme qui est pour Emmanuel
Macron un vrai marqueur de son mandat il
y a un bras de fer qui est engagé
je pense qu'il doit y avoir pas
forcément encore une certaine fébrilité
mais en tout cas une prise de conscience
que on verra ce soir on attend 17h les
chiffres de la préfecture ce des
syndicats qui seront évidemment 30-45
ans
qui seront sans doute 40 ou 50 % plus
haut mais je pense que déjà ce matin on
observait quand même dans les
préfectures et on avait des retours
d'une forte très forte mobilisation les
sondages
petit à petit non le français parce que
vous êtes pour ou contre cette réforme
le but c'est assez partagé et puis plus
ça avance plus les Français semblent
être contre cette réforme surtout le
report de l'âge de départ voilà pourquoi
plus le temps passe plus le gouvernement
occupe l'espace c'est ce qui avait
demandé manuel Macron quand c'est des
ministres il y a deux jours genre
expliquer expliquer encore
plus les ministres expliquent les
Français sont contre je sais pas s'il y
a une un rapport entre l'explication des
ministres et l'opposition des Français
je pense que plus la communication se
fait sur la nature de cette réforme plus
peut-être les Français ils ont opposés
c'est une aussi une possibilité c'est à
dire que au fur et à mesure que les
jours passent et que l'information sur
la nature de cette réforme se diffuse
dans la société peut-être que les
Français se disent ah oui j'avais pas
vraiment réalisé de quoi il s'agit et ce
à quoi je vais avoir droit
pour la suite je pense que les Français
ont entendu aussi pour certains d'entre
eux en tout cas c'est à gauche ce que
les les parties et les syndicats veulent
dire c'est que le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites qui étaient organismes qui
avait été chargé de corps absolument
un de de faire un rapport en amont de
cette réforme et et bon les sept à 10
milliards de cumuler dans le temps ne
semble peut-être pas totalement
insurmontable aux français quand on leur
donne aussi les montants par exemple les
supports dont peuvent bénéficier des
entreprises privées et qui sont des
dizaines de fois plus élevés c'est
peut-être réducteur ça allait sans doute
et c'est un discours populaire populiste
surtout pardon
mais les Français ne sont peut-être pas
insensibles et je pense que voilà ils
ont la conviction que cette d'une
certaine réalité c'est à dire que cette
réforme la volonté de réforme et
peut-être autant voir plus politique que
vraiment économique
on peut le retrouver Timothée Delam dans
un instant Timothée
par les pompiers
si vous voulez toutes les informations
les images en bas à gauche cette image
les images en bas à droite c'est Vincent
heureusement que le reste c'est les
flics évidemment vous voyez ces images
de la place de la vallée jusqu'à nation
j'ai l'impression que ça va prendre du
temps Sophie oui ça va prendre du temps
et cette marche là oui et c'est d'autant
plus impressionnant qui fait quand même
un froid de canard ça fait une
demi-heure maintenant que je suis revenu
de la place de la République et j'ai
encore des fourmis dans les mains
il faisait vraiment je pense proche de
zéro peut-être pas tout à fait mais
enfin voilà et donc ça aussi c'est un
élément fort de significatif les
conditions météo sont pas rassemblées
pour voilà favoriser une descente dans
la rue et pourtant il y avait du monde
et je pense que ce n'est pas la dernière
mobilisation et c'est ça qui est aussi
important à dire à vos auditeurs
je les transmets à Sophie qui est encore
quelques minutes avec nous je les laisse
rentrer après parce qu'elle était sur la
manifestation à des papiers à écrire et
puis sur filaro.fr évidemment pourquoi
pas la dernière on est sûr de ça alors
oui on sait qu'il y aura d'autres
grandes journées pour ceux que vous avez
bourreau votre collègue au service
politique nous me disait tout à l'heure
il faut que ce soit tout de suite fort
mais pas trop fort pour pouvoir faire
mieux le coup d'après oui ça c'est
toujours évidemment la montée en
puissance il peut y avoir soit plus fort
le coup d'après soit partout ailleurs en
France aussi
il peut y avoir ça y est là on voit
quelques quelques quelques petites
fumées qui ne ressemblent pas à celles
des syndicats les forces de l'ordre à
droite devant
voilà ça commence un petit peu à se
lancer souvent à ce moment-là les fameux
lancer de de de pétards sur les forces
de
on va essayer de mettre les images en
plein écran comme ça on rattra rien et
puis on continue de parler dessus
Sophie en espérant que ça débordements
soient marginaux comme toujours sans
doute permettre à une colonne de se
déployer
avec les photographes qui ont l'air
quand même assez cool fumer leur
cigarette à côté moi les photographes
sont de bons indicateurs pour moi c'est
à dire que je les repères quand je les
repères et que je les vois un peu tendus
je me recule
on voit là c'est un jeune
masqué cagoulés qui attendent un petit
peu l'affrontement qui le cherche on
reste sur ces images je me dis Ariel
Becky en régie mais j'interroge Timothée
Delens Timothée
qu'en est-il est-ce que vous voyez des
débordements des échauffourés vous êtes
en train de remonter en tête de cortège
la fumée des gaz lacrymogènes en plus
nos images dites moi toute Timothée
absolument Tibo en tête de cortège
sachant qu'il y a je vous le rappelle
deux itinéraires qui ont été tracés cet
après-midi car il y a beaucoup de monde
nous nous sommes sur ce boulevard
Voltaire à 1 km à peu près de la place
de la Nation en kilomètres normalement
en marche ça se fait très rapidement
mais là je peux vous dire qu'il va
falloir qu'il va falloir beaucoup de
temps pour arriver sur cette sur cette
place de la Nation parce que tout
simplement nous sommes en train de
piétiner ça se voit peut-être pas dans
l'immédiat là parce qu'il y a un petit
un petit trou mais vous vous le voyez
sur ces images de Julien Leclerc qui va
vous faire un panneau voilà beaucoup de
monde cette ce boulevard Voltaire qui
est en fait tout simplement noir de
monde et vous le voyez il y a des jeunes
des moins jeunes voilà beaucoup beaucoup
de monde beaucoup de toutes les
générations sont sont là sont
représentées vous me demandiez Thibault
s'il y avait des heures moi
personnellement je n'en ai vu aucun pour
l'instant plutôt plus de bon enfant
d'ailleurs vous le voyez sur les sur les
visages on voit que il y a pas
particulièrement de tension ici on
entend plutôt les tambours j'ai presque
envie de vous dire que c'est une
ambiance bon enfant en tout cas en ce
qui nous concerne je ne sais pas ce qui
se passe au niveau de la place de la
Bastille ou bien au niveau de nation je
n'y suis pas encore arrivé mais ici la
foule les manifestants qui continuent
d'avancer tranquillement j'allais dire
vers cette place de la Nation
ce fils comme le petit moteur voilà on a
vu ces images mais dans ce que nous
disent nos reporters sur place pour
l'instant c'est assez calme alors
c'était prévisible
à 50 ou 100 mètres d'un point très chaud
sans pouvoir percevoir tant la foule
danse alors évidemment vous entendez des
explosions mais c'est compliqué de
savoir exactement de quoi il s'agit
quand on n'est pas sur place et il peut
y avoir des micro-tension aussi des
déclenchements voilà il y a pas
forcément de phénomène massif qui
impactent toute la marche surtout quand
elle était aussi longue et en plus comme
la très bien dit notre confrère séparé
en deux cortèges moi j'ai vu le le
lancement du corps de la société Vincent
il y a un instant comme cela n'avançait
pas il y a eu une autorisation pour
passer par un
une grande boulevard parallèle
et de fait c'est tout de même assez rare
moi j'ai peu assisté à cela
c'est aussi sans doute une façon pour
fluidifier le cortège d'éviter le
surplace le surplace qui peut être
propice aussi aux tensions aux
agacements donc il faut que ça avance il
faut que ça cool la préfecture peut
avoir décidé ça en co-organisation avec
les responsables de la marche donc
responsable syndicaux
et on voyait les points fixes des
politiques tout à l'heure plutôt du côté
du Cirque d'Hiver je pense que là ils
sont en train soit de s'ébranler dans la
marche soit de partir les uns et les
autres à leurs vœux et c'est à ce
moment-là alors veut parce que je c'est
la période où tous les parlementaires
vont à leur veut respectifs et c'est
souvent à ce moment-là c'est-à-dire
quand quand la foule bon enfant commence
à se
connaître pas être encore le cas et je
vous dis la mobilisation est très forte
aujourd'hui et donc évidemment le temps
tout s'étale un peu plus dans le temps
de dernière question sur ce qui va se
passer à l'Assemblée donc on parle de ça
se passe aujourd'hui dans la rue et qui
mieux que Vincent rozeron qui est sur
place pour nous dire ce qui se passe
dans la rue ce qui se passe autour de
nous Vincent
visiblement vous avancez enfin c'était
pas le cas depuis le début de la journée
ça avait du mal à se lancer cette
manifestation non oui
oui
effectivement alors attendez je me suis
mis rapidement vous montrer un peu ce
qui se passe de mon côté on a
effectivement on a beaucoup marché là
depuis quelques temps on a pris ce que
je voulais tout à l'heure c'est
l'itinéraire parallèles en fait on a
arrêté d'aller vers Bastille on a vers
nation directement en fait ça a été fait
comme ça pour que ce soit plus facile
d'ailleurs je suis avec un manifestant
de la de la CFTC hop je vais tourner ma
caméra bonjour ça a mis du temps avancer
cette manifestation bonjour oui je sais
pas s'il y a eu des problèmes au début
de cortège mais nous là on avance bien
maintenant mais apparemment c'est bien
bouché quelque part on sait pas trop où
en fait pour l'instant là ça va on
commence à bouger quoi alors juste pour
parler quand même cette manifestation
des retraites rouges c'est quand même
très important de venir ici oui c'est
très important parce que faut que
Monsieur Macron et Madame borne grave ça
sur le marbre l'Élysée les Français ne
veulent pas mourir au travail en fait
faut pas faut pas qu'on meurt au travail
alors tous les syndicats sont ici
aujourd'hui c'est sympa c'est une
puissance comme ce Macron et Madame
borne doivent doivent voir comme voilà
les Français ne veulent pas mourir au
travail faut que ça soit gravé chez eux
là oui et et la CFTC qui est là avec
tous les organismes syndicaux c'est
quand même une grande première oui c'est
une grande première et c'est puissant
c'est très puissant on parle d'un
million de personnes on sait pas trop
faut pas non plus on verra ça plus tard
mais c'est puissant tous les syndicats
ne veulent pas qu'on meurt au travail
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur voilà
et alors je vais vous montrer quelque
chose d'assez surprenant c'est que fait
le le deuxième itinéraire qui vient
d'ouvrir à l'instant
la circulation vient d'être aussi
rouverte en fait juste derrière ça y est
la situation est ouverte qu'ils ont
voilà vidé en fait la place de la
République grâce à ça et en passant par
ce boulevard Voltaire qui va amener en
fait directement à la place de la Nation
en fait la voiture balai mon cher
Vincent roseron allez-y remontez
progressivement
dans le cortège Sophie vous nous tendez
votre portable et vous me donnez un
chiffre 400000 manifestants à Paris
selon le syndicat CGT
d'autres je regarde je me permets face à
vous de
d'essayer de trouver cette info
évidemment ce sont les sites de la CGT
et dire à ceux de la police
tout à l'heure il nous a dit que la
police
envisageait plutôt entre 50 et 80 000
que ce pourrait être un peu au-dessus au
vu de la tendance
qu'il y avait dans les autres villes de
France ce matin sur les différentes
manifestations à Marseille en Nice à
Lyon à Nantes etc etc donc on s'attend à
un peu plus que 80000 personnes 50 90
personnes
non sans doute là si je dis plus 50%, on
serait nettement je ne vois pas encore
pour l'instant
non je ne vois pas on va les chiffres
vont tomber petit à petit vous me
parliez de l'Assemblée tout à l'heure
oui allez on y vient on parle un peu de
l'Assemblée Sophie parce que il y a deux
combats pour le gouvernement celui de la
rue finalement s'il y a du monde c'est
forcément un problème pour le
gouvernement pour Isabelle borne et pour
Emmanuel Macron c'est pas la seule
problématique parce qu'il faut en plus
de ça gagner et faire voter ce texte à
l'Assemblée nationale 20 ans que ce
serait plus ou moins validé que la
droite aiderait
est-ce que c'est sûr est-ce que c'est
fait ça il y a trois courants au sein de
la droite ce qu'on dit habituellement
c'est-à-dire un courant qui est plutôt
proche de de la majorité présidentielle
un courant qui est plutôt entre les deux
et un courant qui est plutôt très opposé
et plutôt
tourné vers d'autres alliances que
celles de l'exécutif celle avec
l'exécutif de fait il y aura donc de la
défection des conditions posées ils
savent qu'ils sont des Kings makers
c'est à dire des faiseurs de roi
voilà
un espace non non vous ne devriez pas
être surpris par le niveau d'anglais des
journalistes du service collectif on va
continuer cette interview en anglais
en italien si vous voulez ça me fera de
bons souvenirs plutôt et puis c'est vrai
que non bref
il y aura aussi des défections au sein
de l'exécutif on l'a vu pour barbara
Pompili et quelques-uns de ceux de son
courant qui ont déjà dit qu'il
voteraient contre mais ne sont que 5 ou
6 absolument ancienne ministre mais qui
sur ce dossier là a clairement dit
qu'elle y était opposée je discutais
l'autre jour avec Benoît Barrault qui
est député de la Côte d'Or et qui lui a
député Renaissance proche de François
Rebsamen et de son courant
social-démocrate
et qui disait lui qu'il allait
s'abstenir et qu'il pourrait pencher
vers une opposition on a vu tout à
l'heure un député liotte absolument qui
nous disait que lui non est plutôt de
centre droit ancien de l'UMP Blanchère
blancheur
c'est la première fois que je suis dans
une manif mais je suis contre donc
ça c'est sûr et ils font partie aussi de
ceux à droite qui ne sont pas donc
proches de l'exécutif et qui peuvent
pour des raisons diverses vouloir
s'opposer à cette réforme
puisque s'opposer à la réforme c'est
aussi s'opposer et évidemment d'être
enchères s'opposer à l'action du
gouvernement c'est une façon de se poser
à l'action du gouvernement
il va y avoir on discutait avec
clémentinotta donc cette députée
insoumise tout à l'heure elle nous a
nous allons déposer des amendements
beaucoup d'amendements mais il faut que
ce soit des amendements intelligents
c'est à dire qu'ils ne veulent pas être
qu'une force d'opposition ils veulent
aussi être une dynamique de proposition
et source d'espoir et c'était un petit
peu la difficulté pour cette gauche qui
est assez loin du pouvoir au moins dans
les sondages c'est de montrer ça change
il y a deux ans et demi où ils avaient
fait passer un paquet assez incroyable
d'amendement avec des amendements qui
étaient tous les mêmes dans cette vidéo
alors si il y en aura forcément mais ils
ne veulent pas faire que cela et ils
veulent surtout diffuser un message
d'opposition intelligente c'est à dire
donner envie finalement aux Français
pour ceux des Français qui vont assister
au débat parlementaire parce qu'il faut
tout de même rappeler que les débats
parlementaires sont aussi et beaucoup
des débats d'initiés pour des personnes
politisées qui sont engagées dans la
reine
de la démocratie
ça peut être long et un peu technique un
peu technique et pas forcément très
grand public et donc l'image qu'ils
veulent donner c'est une image
constructive d'opposition qui n'est pas
que dans l'obstruction mais qui veut
donner de l'espoir et donc c'est un fil
un peu étroit un chemin un peu étroit
sur lequel ils veulent s'engager ce que
nous lisait Clémentine autant et c'est
pour ça qu'ils sont dans la rédaction en
ce moment d'une contre proposition avec
notamment des engagements des
propositions de solutions financières
pour justement parvenir à réduire ce
dont nous parlions tout à l'heure qui
est ce déficit cumulé entre 7 et 10
milliards 12 milliards peut-être pour
certains euh de de des retraites jusque
l'avenir 2070 et donc cette gauche qui
veut montrer que tout ne voilà ce n'est
pas que un nom mais c'est aussi on peut
faire autrement et c'est ce qu'ils
veulent montrer dans le débat
parlementaire
est-ce que la droite elle sera ma
dernière question c'est aussi après je
vous relâche la droite peut s'allier
être d'accord entre elles déjà ça c'est
une vraie question on dit souvent
j'entends souvent votre part d'ailleurs
des journalistes du Figaro sont des
indépendants les députés LR qui font un
peu ce qu'ils veulent chacun de leur
côté alors je sais que vous suivez la
gauche mais vous avez les retours de vos
collègues est-ce que elles vont si
erikiotti un nouveau boss DLR si Olivier
Marleix le président des députés LR à
l'assemblée décide de voter en faveur de
cette loi avec Emmanuel Macron et les
siens est-ce que tout seront dans cette
ligne et bien écoutez je ne pense pas
que le mot godillot soit tout à fait
adapté les concernant surtout en ce
moment étant donné les tensions qu'il y
a entre élections et aux novota yo des
tensions liées évidemment à
l'organisation du gouvernement DLR qui
est assez compliqué